il se déroule en présentiel ou en ligne
vivez et comprenez en direct les parties
des meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec
les commentaires en français de nos
experts notre moteur d'analyse
l'explorateur d'ouverture et les tables
base retrouvez toutes les infos
essentielles comme le programme les
horair des rondes les prix les résultats
les cont rendus quotidien les bios des
joueurs les règles des partages et plus
encore vous pouvez même participer à la
compétition en pronostiquant les
résultats pour tenter de gagner des
abonnements premium alors rendez-vous
dès maintenant sur chess com/events
aussi bien sur le site internet que sur
nos applications iOS et Android pour
vivre votre passion comme nulle par
[Musique]
ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les amis je vous enlève un peu ce
cet écran de pause mais je sais pas trop
quoi vous dire parce que c'était censé
commencer
à
à 19h à 17h pardon
mais il manque encore la cam de Wesley
je sais pas trop ce qui se passe en
fait bon on va voir on va voir les
matchs mais on va voir le match entre
Maxim et NPO ça sentait pas ça sent pas
l'enthousiasme du côté des deux Maxime
ça sentait pas les les gros sourires y
non plus donc ça peut ça peut
troll on verra on verra bien ce que ça
ça
donne alors par contre est-ce
que
euh pourquoi on a plus les
cam euh pourquoi est-ce qu'on a a plus
les
cames attendez hein parce que moi je les
vois
encore mais il s'est passé un truc
euh
attendez il s'est passé un
truc qui la mais j'ai j'ai un bug j'ai
un bug
bizarre là on a les
cam et là un bug est arrivé
attendez
hein je vraiment désolé je comprends pas
pourquoi
ok euh le problème est tant que
je
euh ça rend
fou bon il se ouais ouais je crois que
bah ils se sont écrit hier je crois
qu'ils vont sous les de la même chose
donc
c'est un peu
complexe on va faire comme
ça et on va faire l'inverse
ici
C qui chante ouais
c'est ah désolé mais je pouvais pas
régler le le petit le petit bug
autrement on va suivre
Maxime on parle beaucoup de J aussi Peru
écoute frérot on va pas parler de ça
c'est c'est comme ça si
tu si tu penses que ils sont suspects
juste ne regardent pas en fait enfin je
sais pas trop quoi dire à vrai
dire je sais pas trop quoi vous
dire je sais pas quoi quoi vous répondre
par rapport à ça chacun se se fait son
avis laave qu'il veut et libre de de
regarder ou pas après hein qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je peux vous dire on va
partir du du principe que c'est possible
et je sais pas c'est comme si à Roland
Garros tu avais le 150e et le 125e
mondial qui était tous les deux en
demi-finale et qui avait
éliminé j'en sais rien moi rude t pass
et et M VDF
quoi c'est après tu crois ou tu'y crois
pas après ça c'est c'est
ton c'est ton souci mais nous on peut
pas on peut pas y faire
grand-chose NP qui s face à mvl ouais je
crois que je crois que ça peut troll
fort là le match mvl contre
NPO connaissant les deux lousti à mon
avis ça peut troll fort donc ça peut
donner des parties
amusantes
à mon avis ça peut donner des des
parties assez assez amusantes parce que
les deux vont avoir envie juste de
s'amuser je suis pas sûr qu'ils a ni
l'un ni l'ARE très envie de se qualifier
enfin je veux dire pas qu'ils ai pas
envie genre s'il se qualifi ils vont se
qualifier mais genre je suis pas sûr
qu'ils y tiennent tant que ça donc je
pense qu'ils sont surtout là pour se
faire plaisir et et s'amuser ils vont
juste essayer de de faire des des
parties qui leur plaisent
quoi on dit le M c'est fait sortir avec
cl amateur plusieurs fois non mais ça
existe enfin tu peux multiplier les les
les exploit et faire et faire tout le
temps des exploits et faire une vie
d'exploit
enfin c'est complètement possible
c'est pas comment dire il se voit
respectivement ouais il se voi c'est pas
impossible
hein ça existe les obset et tu peux tu
peux faire tout le temps des obset
toutes les semainesfin pourquoi
pas
bon mais ça peut donner des belles
parties là dans le dans le loser
bracket max avec le sourire allez c'est
parti
enfin le 4 5 KF3 kf6 c'est non y qui on
aurait pu s'attendre à à quelqu'un qui
nous fait plaisir aïe aïe aïe a AE il me
fait mentir y décide de jouer sa petov
quand même bon Maxime ça sans que il
veut troll je le connais très très bien
Maxime je connais très très bien mon
Maxime et là je peux vous dire qu'il
réfléchit à qu'est-ce que je peux jouer
pour avoir une partie amusante il a
envie de s'amuser Maxime aujourd'hui
c'est pour ça que je voulais regarder ce
match et je m'attendais à ce que Yan
aussi nous offre un jeu ouvert
ah voilà un petit fou
des3 et ça va jouer avec COC et C4 je
pense
le beau
jeu Maxime qui réfléchit
déjà so et fouja il se voit du coup
ouais bah
après
ok joue dame2 fou
E7 donc ça donne un pion pour l'activité
côté côté Yan le pion est pris et
rockrock et il y a pas mal d'activité là
pour les Noirs à venir on va voir si
Maxime peut
contrôler cette attaque ou
pas et dans l'autre partie al c'est
firou qui a les blancs aussi hein comme
ça on est deux fois côté français je
vais pas changer les cames à chaque fois
sinon ça va être un peu indigeste mais
voilà voilà l'ouverture
ah mais
attendez parce que là j'ai la partie
légèrement décalé attendez une
seconde parce que là j'ai la partie
légèrement
décalé alors ne touchez à rien
ne touche à rien on peut être un peu en
avance sur le j'ai remarqué avec leur
caméra j'ai remarqué avec les caméras
c'est pour ça que je les voyais sourire
à
contettemps et oui parce que il y a j'ai
une manière
spéciale d'avoir les
coups c'est un pion de plus normalement
c'est cavalier C6 je crois le
coup et dame prend tour
prend et la position est censée aller
pour pour notre ami
Yan et qui s fait plir de revoir
maximeah on l'a vu hier déjà mais lazavi
était vraiment très fort c'est un genre
de mur qui renvoie les bares les barres
moi les
balles c'est un petit peu écrit avec
avec Maxime
rapidement
il m'a dit tu as vraiment l'impression
de de taper contre contre un mur qui
renvoie toutes les balles ça jou
vraiment très très bien
hier donc fou
3 il faut F6
C3
et donc dans l'autre partie on va voir
c'est un peu plus
avancé ça c'est all avec les Blancs
j'aime bien sa
position Maxim quand un pion de
plus il va peut-être
pouvoir obtenir l'avantage dans cette
finale je dis obtenir parce que pour le
moment les noirs sont censés avoir assez
de
contrejeu voilà partie sur les lunettes
de Maxim en fait ouais moi je enin C
avec la mimique mon il a fait une
mimique de quelqu'un qui avait joué et
et il avait pas joué donc cavalier d de
Maxime qui va stabiliser sa position
pour moi les blancs sont mieux ici he il
y a quand même ce pion de plus alors je
suis convaincu que la prépa de de Yan et
que la finale tient
objectivement mais mais voilà pour moi
un pion de plus c'est un pion de plus he
pour un être
humain l'être humain n'a pas le le sang
froid enfin la machine n' même pas de
mais mais pour un joueur comme Maxime ça
c'est sûr que les blancs sont mieux il
fait fou F5 après y il s'est beaucoup
entraîné sur ces positions là c'est
position qui important de savoir tenir
notamment pour les candidats ou pour les
matchs mais bon c'est dur à mentalement
de jouer ses positions à répétition avec
avec les Noirs parce que c'est tu as
zéro chance de gain tu es sous pression
franchement
Yan son changement de répertoire il faut
être solide dans la tête he pour
l'assumer et il estest c'est pour ça
qu'il a gagné deux fois les candidats et
qu'il a failli être champion du monde il
a é vraiment proche de de Bat Ding
Len donc B3 ah 5 fout D4
ouais moi j'aime
bien moi j'aime bien pour
euh pour les blancs mais je vois la
turbine continue à afficher proche des
gales mais on peut déjà regarder quand
même du Fou B6 fou prend A5 hein qui
peut vite
arriver très très
agréable extrêmement agréable pour les
blancs je suis curieux de voir si Anne
va être capable de de la
tenir après quand les joueurs se
préparent à jouer ce genre de ligne il
faut il faut savoir qu'ils s'entraînent
ils font des matchs d'entraînement sur
ces positions donc ils acquèrent un
feeling qui peut leur permettre de de
trouver les
coups et de jouer vraiment à des à des
niveaux très
élevé sur cavalier C5 je me demande si
la finale avec les fot de couleur opposé
est facile à à tenir je pense que Maxim
va plutôt jouer fou C5 et cavalier D4
ici pour essayer
de de changer ses pièces alors est-ce
que sur fou C5 on peut jouer fou prend
B3 mais il y a fou prend E7 et on
attaque la tour donc on peut pas je
pense qu'il va faire fou C5 ici Maxime
il le fait et fou F6 cavalier D4 je
pense et fou prendre D4 peut-être on
peut prendre du pion qui sa et augmenter
la
pression qui sait
ouais je continue à dire que que les
Blancs ont un réel
avantage fou F6 il veut garder la paire
de
fou donc fou B6 F prend 5 il va y avoir
un problème avec le le cavalier B3 qui
va tomber mais va peut-être jouer fo3
pour consolider son pion et après
repartir avec le cavalier on va voir ce
que fait
al position
complexe il y a pas d'écart fait dans la
partie
entre
Wesley
tout cas
mvl un légère
avantage ça c'est
évident il remet le fou en D4 donc il
vair
refou7 Maxime qui doit vouloir tourner
le schmilb dans un
sens il doit vouloir venir tourner le
schmilblig dans un autre
sens bon le fou devrait revenir en le
set ici je vois pas trop pourquoi il
ferait autre chose je le vois pas
tolérer le foupr F6 et en
échange
ça paraîtrait pas logique entre
guillemets donc il prend prend et prend
wou euh
ouais ok
courageux donc là ce qu'il a vu c'est
tour A2 tour tour D8 je suppose mais il
y a peut-être B4 ici tour prend B2 puis
on prend
A5 tour
B5 A6 tour B6 à 7 tour
B7 alors B4 tour prend B2 puis on prend
tour B5 est-ce que on
[Musique]
a une manière de prendre l'avantage
Maxime qui trouve pas alors je veux
juste voir pourquoi l'ordi aimait bien
parce que c'est vrai que visuellement on
a du mal à comprendre ah il y avait tour
à 6 à la fin pour tour prend C6 ok bon
c'est pas sûr que ça a gagné he pour le
coup mais mais c'était un vrai avantage
raté par Maxim mais très difficile très
difficile parce qu'il fallait comprendre
qu'on Pousse Pousse Pousse Pousse Pousse
pour avoir tour àass à la fin c'était
vraiment pas
facile pour moi ce n'était vraiment pas
facile comme
variante donc ça a pas été trouvé par
Maxime qui a eu la petite opportunité
alors il veut quand même jouer sur tour
B8 t prend A5 tour prend B3 tour C5 tour
B6 avoir cette tour mieux placé qui peut
donner un petit avantage avec du Tour E4
tour C4 ou tour F4 je comprends ce que
veut faire Maxime en fait c'est vrai que
s'il met les deux tours sur C4 et C5 le
pion F6 serait condamné donc il va
prendre A5 sur tour D2 il y a toujours
tour F5 donc je vois bien jouer tour C5
ici ah il veut tour
D3 à tour D3 qui est malin parce que
tour C1 tour B6 et tour A1 tour
B3 Yan qui veut jouer un peu au jeu du
chat et de la souris alors il fait tour
TR en premier j'allais vous proposer ce
coup
pour poser un problème et maintenant il
y a tour B5 ou tour D5 Yan qui va
échanger les pions et on va on va partir
sur une partie
nulle on peut pas laisser la priorité
sur la colonne C si on prend D5 il va
reprendre il va peut-être jouer roi F1
RO2 ro D3 roi D4 alors il a encore un
tout petit
truc mais qui va pas durer très
longtemps là il va faire tour D3 tour C2
roi G2 je
pense et roi F3 H4 ro E3 F4 ro D4 s'il
peut il joue avec ro
E1 alors il veut faire ça comment roi G7
il veut jouer pour tour
E2 c'est assez
ingénieux avec l'idée sur tour prend roi
prend de d'être en premier en D4 dans la
finale de pion donc il veut provoquer
tour B1 roi D2 F5 roi E3 roi F6 roi roi
D4 tour D1 roi C5 ça doit être nul mais
Maxime qui essaie de
prétendre un petit quelque
chose il a raison il a
raison la position
est et
complexe
maxime a pas à donner Laan nulle
gratuitementin il n'a pas à donné la nul
gratuitement il va faire roi E3 ici non
ça doit être nul quand même alirea
est-ce qu'il a quelque chose ou
pas l'ordinateur donne égal la position
est assez chaotique mais ça doit être
égal aussi ça peut partir sur de Nules
hein mesdames et messieurs dans ces deux
premières parties donc là c'est le la
Manche des perdants hein ça va beaucoup
plus vite
s deux parties gagnantes
simplement Maxime qui voudrait mettre
mettre la pression il calcule ro E3 tour
D1 il aurait tour des de quand
même ro3 roi G6 fait roi C2 sur tour H1
il a quand même H4 tour 1 des de tour A5
C B3 et il peut peut-être casser la la
connexion entre la tour et le pion
j'aime j'apprécie énormément ce que fait
Maxime
ici donc il fait tour F1 et là l'ordi
kiffe tour D2 et oui parce que l'ordi
veut tour D2 roi D3 roi
E2 non il veut peut-être pas ça il veut
tour D2 peut-être ro D2 roi E3 tour C1
roi D4 puis tour D3 roi prend D5 c'est
on sent que ça chauffe là pour Yan
ok alors pourquoi est-ce qu'il faut
absolument jouer GH l'ordi veut
absolument GH GH tour H1 c'est sûrement
le le coup qu'on veut pas voir ah il y a
peut-être tour D4 tour H2 tour F4 ah je
suis pas sûr de moi c'est c'est vraiment
très compliqué comme final attendez je
je me pose la question donc j'ai envie
d'avoir la rép ah oui non il y a T Pr 5
je suis débile et ouais ça ça va être
gagnant ça c'est gagnant c'est sûr le
roi est
coupé et Maxime qui rate à JH c'était
hyper fort ça gagné quasiment il fait
F4 mais je comprends en fait il veut HG
HG tour F3 tour prend D5 tour prend G3
tour
D4 ah ça ressemble tellement à l'autre
ouais non ça en fait ça donne
l'impression d'être gagnant c'est
terrible en fait on a on se dit qu'on va
jouer C4 ici ou
F5 d'ailleurs F5 ça paraît hyper fort
wou j'aurais l'impression d'être gagnant
après
F5 j'aurais réellement l'impression
d'être gagnant après F5 parce que F5 tu
veux C4 C5 C6 C7 C8 ouis il a pas de bol
là
Maxime la position donne réellement
l'impression d'être
gagnante
et là c'est de nouveau et là c'est
gagnant ro B4 et C4 bon maisf
lesvaluation de l'ordinateur en fait
elle au coup par coup il y a que ro B4
qui gagne mais c'est le coup logique et
pourquoi est-ce que ro G6 n'est pas le
bon coup ça
c'est c'est mystère et boules de gomme
que visuellement la finale était
gagnante mesdames et
messieurs et et là les pions le pion qui
va pousser donc
Maxime devrait s'imposer dans cette
première
partie et oui parce que maintenant sur
F5 F5 C4 roi
F6 peut-être on peut même jouer tour5
qui sait je pense qu'il va faire F5 ro
F6 bon en tout cas ça devrait ça devrait
gag
ici pour
Maxime F5
C4 mais genre par exemple il se trouve
que tour des6 F6 n'est pas gagnant ah là
Lord s'en fiche je crois F6 C5 et ro E6
il recule probablement juste en D4 et il
avance
ouais je m'attends à ah est-ce que tour
des4 tour4
marche c'est une excellente question
donc C5 va jouer tour 4 3 B5 tour prend
alle C5 ça va aller hyper
vite parce que la tour est bien placée
pour contrer la la Tour
Noire difficile là pour Yan très
difficile pour
Yan extrêmement difficile en
réalité
mais oui on comprend pourquoi la finale
est gagnante he c'est quasiment
l'équivalent d'un pion de
plus et donc on comprend que ce soit
gagnant après il devait y avoir des une
manière de faire nul avec un jeu
extrêmement précis pour Yan mais c'était
vraiment dur à trouver probablement
c'était introuvable humainement
humainement la finale semble semble
gagnante ce que je vous ai dit d'
d'ailleurs j'étais très étonné que
l'évaluation soit soit simplement
égale c'était vraiment très très
étonnant donc ça va être une première
victoire pour
Maxime donc s'il gagne aujourd'hui on le
retrouvera demain dans
le dans le braquet des
laosé
on le retrouvera dans le braquet
deslosé et donc il jouera contre le
perdant du oh là il jouera contre le
perdant de l'énorme match mesdames et
messieurs il jouera contre le perdant du
M event
demain
et oui puisquil jouera
contre il jouera contre le perdant du
match qui oppose aujourd'hui le Main
Event qui oppose la zavi contre
jospem les deux stars de ce
format j'imagine que tour 5 fonctionne
pas à cause de tour prend on prend F4
roi B6 à si ça fonctionne F3 C7 F2 C8
dame échec il veut quoi alors sur
tour5 ah il voulait roi D6 et T prend 4
puis on prend là ça fonctionne plus si
ça fonctionnait quand même
ou il a tenté un piège qui marchait pas
en fait ce qui est très
beau il a tenté un piège qui ne
fonctionnait pas
y
bon là il va y avoir tour des 8 C H
dames c'est terminado Yan qui va
concéder la la défaite
ouais il a concédé ça y est c'est merci
au revoir victoire de Maxime ça nous met
très bien et on va aller
voir côté alira contre il y a eu match
nul ok première partie
terminée Maxime qui s'est imposé dans
cette
finale
sommes toutes
complexe et voilà le premier point pour
Maxime Maxime qui s'impose et on va
revoir là c'est la partie d'aliera qui
avait les blancs mais j'imagine qu'il
s'est pas passé
grand-chose alors je sais pas si demain
je ferai un recap un recap YouTube très
très franchement
j'ai hésité à le faire hier d'ailleurs
il a pas du tout marché malheureusement
parce que j'ai réussi à faire quelque
chose quand même de bien mais
honnêtement les parties étaient vraiment
inintéressante euh il faut il faut dire
la vérité on voit pas des beaux échecs
hein dans ce dans ce
tournoi pour le moment c'est pas des des
très belles
parties alors cette partie là est assez
sympa
en terme de gestion de finale
mais mais oui pour dire la vérité on n
pas on n pas vu des des très beaux
échecs jusqu'à
maintenant après on sait qu' est un peu
un tilter quand ça se passe
mal pour ça je pensais que Maxime était
grand grand favori pour le match
d'aujourd'hui
Maxime pas là pour B sandwich non un
recap de laavic J spem bah le problème
c'est que ils font pas des super B
partie généralement la zavic et
jospem ils ont un style un peu
particulier surtout la zavic en fait la
zavic qui joue jamais le gain il essaie
même pas de presser les petits avantages
globalement il joue des trucs assez
inspides et il punit que les gaffes mais
son énorme point fort à la zavic c'est
que il fait très peu de gaffe lui-même
et il est très très très très difficile
à
battre
en gros il temporise beaucoup les
parties il fait il est il est pas il est
pas entreprenant jamais et c'est comme
ça qu'il a gagné le match hier contre
Maxime finalement avec avec cette
stratégie des Nules et de l'armagedon
mais c'est c'est vrai qu'il a il a un
peu ce ce style de jeu
ou il temporise quoi temporise beaucoup
allez c'est déjà le match retour ça
enchaîne les parties ça c'est bien pas
beaucoup de pause c'est ce qu'on aime
petite nage d'or petit fou des
TR voà 3 de points d'exclamation sur
dame prend des4 il a fou
B5 pourquoi une partie des grands
joueurs d'échec ont des comportements
très particul lors qu'ils perdent un
match on dirait des autistes euh de quoi
tu parles
cercer donc
kig3
donc H4
H5 il y a un petit décalage he pour
répondre aux questions du chat là pour
le moment Maxime qui gère je pense qu'il
va avoir aucun problème dans cette
partie je suppose qu'il ne va avoir
absolument aucun problème
Maxime
je pense qu'il va être
la la dame en à5 je
pense tour
C8
on dirait des sportifs de haut niveau
qui ragent comme au tennis ou autrees
bah il rage pas vraiment les
joueurs je veux dire là hier c'est Jiane
qui
a qui a dévoilé une conversation privée
qu'il avait avec Maxime mais faut
comprendre les joueurs c'est comme si
demain il y avait le Tour de France sans
aucun contrôle dopage et qu'on disait il
y a pas de contrôle antiopage au Tour de
France et que tu as un mec qui finit à
1h45 des leaders et qui tout d'un coup
met 3 ou 4 minutes dans l'Alpe du à tout
le
monde donc je veux dire bah c'est pas
qu'ils sont énervé c'est queils se
posent des questions quoi mais genre là
Yan c'était une conversation privée qui
la
LI mais genre c'est c'est comme si tu
prends un mec qui équip qui prend les
bidons et tout d'un coup bon bah il au
pied de l'Alpe du a il part et bon ben
il lâche tout le monde quoi enfin il met
4 minutes à
pogachar puis te refait ça le lendemain
en en haut du Ventou et puis il te
refait ça tous les jours et puis met
enfin
bon tu es là tu dis bon benah je pouvais
rien faire j'ai roulé au maximum le mec
est trop rapide
enfin mais je là c'était ce ce qu' Rean
c'était une conversation privée ça ça ça
aurait pas dû être partagé sur sur
Twitter c'est c'est c'est plus ça mais
euh mais c'est normal qu'il se pose des
questions
quoi
donc
des5 ok je comprends pas trop pourquoi
c'est si bien pour pour les blancs mais
si tu fais fou pr pu on prend tour des5
tu donnes trop de case
j'imagine m éit d'ord ça tu lui
demanderas mais c'est pas
certain
puis en gros il dit pas grand-chose hein
sur la
conve
il dit pas grand-chose sur le truc qui a
été qui a été
lic
une grosse
part j'ai V les commentaires m ber et
cetera ouais ben en fait oui c'est ça
enfin moi aussi j'ai un petit peu lu sur
redit ce qui s'écrit et
cetera les
amateurs en dessous de 1500 l on va dire
ont pas du tout le
même la même vision des choses que les
joueurs
pro on va dire que pour pour les joueurs
pro
sans sans sans accuser qui que ce soit
de quoi que ce soit mais c'est juste
qu'il se pose des questions quoi c'est
pas toute façon on avait fait
l'interview avec avec krabnck hein il
est en aucun cas correcte d'accuser qui
que ce soit de quoi que ce soit mais
c'est juste que tu tu interrogatif
quoi c'est
[Musique]
pas tu demandes
quoi bonà maxime est vraiment mal j'ai
j'ai raconté n'importe quoi je pensais
qu'il ferait nul
tranquille il est vraiment pas
bien bon il a rien de moins mais
peut-être essayer de faire cavalier F7
et petit ouais mais même petit r tu vas
te faire
ouvrir
bon c'est solide pour le
moment c'est solide pour le moment mais
à mon avis après G4 ça va
imploser ça devrait imploser
là ça fait mal là ça fait mal le
cavalier en D5
M r per contre Carlson ça peut enlever
du non Maxime il a été numéro de mondial
enfin vous pouvez pas comparer quelqu'un
qui était numéro 2 mondial avec
quelqu'un donc le meilleur classement
mondial est 150e quoi
enfin mais ouais bon peu
importe je sais pas il faut comprendre
les joueurs aussi c'est
normal faut pas les prendre pour des
fous qui sont par en fait ils peuvent
pas être tous fous et tous
parano c'est normal de se poser des
questions c'est pas c'est pas malsin que
Maxime se pose des questions ou que Yan
se pose des questions mais ça leur
empêche pas de jouer en fait il il s'en
fiche je vous rassure
hein
s'en fiche y a beaucoup d'argent jeu ils
viennent il
jouent c'est pas très important enfin je
sais pas comment dire il y a beaucoup
d'argent en jeu donc ils sont quand même
contents de participer ils prennent un
beau
chèque c'est pas forcément euh
c'est pas forcément négatif de leur
point de vue je sais pas comment
dire donc tour G1 et alira vous dites
perdant euh on va aller jeter un
œil euh ouais ala est complètement foutu
ouais ouais le fou va aller en B8 alerza
ça va être finito
probablement et Maxime et Maxime cette
partie va la perdre
aussi
si n'importe quel autres sport des
sanctions mesures auraient déjà été
prises à quel encontre
Zenon si tu prends l'exemple de l'port
par exemple qui ressemblerait plus dans
ce cas de figure là au aux échecs entre
guillemets ils font plus aucune
compétition sérieuse full sur Internet
parce qu'il y a beaucoup trop de triche
il y a que les échecs qui font
ça donc non les joueurs dans les autres
eSports auraient
enfin sont aussi monter au
créneau parce qu'il y a trop
d'irrégularité
il y a trop de de choses qui
statistiquement sont pas possibles en
fait j' une temps un peu à côté pour
Maxime
ouais bon comme je dis hein je pense que
s'il perd ça va pas
le il va pas en faire un drame il
préférait gagner mais alirza c'est sûr
qu'il va perdre
pourquoi n'est pas Maxime dans la sauce
comme ça en li provision mais il met pas
Maxime dans la sauce en fait enfin je
sais pas pourquoi vous dites
ça
enin bon comme je disais je pense
que c'est très difficile à expliquer à
des amateurs tous ces trucslà parce que
il faut être pour comprendre le malaise
des joueurs il faut être plus fort aux
échecs pour mieux comprendre les parties
et mieux comprendre plein de
choses
par rapport à ce qui est possible pas
possible mais comme disait Ikaru dans sa
dernière vidéo c'est probablement la fin
des tournois à gros crash price en ligne
je suis assez d'accord avec Ikaru ouais
je je pense comme lui c'est juste que
c'est bien joué F ça menace
cavalier7 c'est juste que ouais les les
events avec beaucoup de cash price sur
Internet sans
contrôle semble comme dans absolument
tous les autres
eSports impossible
organiser on l'avait bien vu aussi avec
l'événement qui avit fait inox
tag sur
fortnite les échecs peuvent pas être le
seul jeu au monde ou même le seul sport
au monde que tu peux pratiquer sans
contrôle je veux dire que
c'est c'est comme ça dans absolument
tous les pans de la vie hein si tu
enlèves la police les juges que tu
enlèves
tout c'est dans tout comme
ça
au suj de compétion sur Inter il aussi
le poker avec de l'argent jeu et de plus
en plus de scandales notamment cash game
sortent au grand jour ben ouais mais
c'est c'est comme ça mais il y avait
aussi toute la période covid avec tous
les examens en ligne et cetera enfin on
sait bien que c'est pas possible en fait
ça marche
pas mais c'est bizarre que les gens
fassent passer Maxime pour un gros rageu
surtout que là il s'est fait juste lune
conversation
privée
gagnante le roi est tellement faible il
va avoir du cavalier échec tu dans
quelques coup
là 14
cavalier5 et après ça men prend H6
prendend H6 G7 tour H7 mat peut-être
quelque chose comme ça ça peut on peut
avoir
content de voir qu'il un discours plus
mesuré qu' sur J dans les deux cas ah
bah c'est pas mesuré il est génial dans
les deux cas enfin il a pas être
mesuré ala qui est peut-être en train de
l'arnaquer c'est pas mesuré
enfin c'est c'est bien dans les deux cas
enfin soit il est très fort soit enfin
il est très fort dans tous les cas en
fait il n y a pas de monde où il est pas
très fort il est très bon dans ce qu'il
fait quoi quoi qu'il en soit moi
j'espère que qu'il joue juste très bien
aux échecs hein on va voir peut-être
qu'alera va pas la
perdre donc fou G5 ouais et ça va mater
pour Yan donc on aura un arm
àagedon
F est peut-être en train de filouter
ouais on va aller voir
après Maxime ça va perdre il y a pas pas
manière d'éviter le mat parce qu'en fait
il y a dame prend H6 là ouais F prend H6
t prend H6 et tour H7 mat comme prévu il
est joli le mat on va le je vais vous le
montrer jusqu'au bout c'est un très joli
mat mat allez on va aller voir
aliera parce que c'est
peut-être pas si simple pour
Wesley
étonnamment
on va voir on va voir ce que ça
donne et D4 qui donne un avantage
décisif au noir maintenant après H3 la
partie peut complètement tourner pour
pour
alirea on va voir s'il le trouve ce sera
assez dingue et c'est trouvé FO al qui
va peut-être revenir du Diable vaau Vert
on on regardera on regardera cette
partie ah ouais parce qu'en fait ça
menace ça menace puis on prend tout
bêtement et fou H3 ouais Wesley qui a
explosé donc il tente cavalier G5 c'est
logique donc là il va jouer h pr G2 roi
prend l'ordinateur qui annonce in 11
mais il faut avoir
encore je comprends pas la ligne de gain
ah ça y est j'ai compris l'ordi veut HG
roi prend G2 H1 échec tour prend H1 et
cavalier F4 oh c'est dur à trouver
Hin et si tu fais cavalier F4 direct
c'est qu'il y a pas de math oh c'est pas
c'est pas simple à
trouver c'est vraiment pas simple parce
que roi H2 cavalier F4 ro H2 tour H8
c'est ce que tu regardes roi G1 et tu
rentres là-dedans normalement et tu
penses qu'il y a un gain donc tu
calcules forcément ça cavalier E2 roi G2
x H3 attendez pour moi il y a un gain ah
donc cavalier F4 il y a roi
H1 ok donc en fait fait il faut qu'il
arrive à cavalier F4 3 H1 et sur fou G4
il y a dame prend E5 donc il y a pas de
gain ah il fait tour H8 d'abord tour H8
je pense que c'est bien
joué je pense que c'est très bien joué
parce que sur rochin maintenant il a
fougé 4 non fou G4 il y a F3 ah c'est
pas gagné encore c'est pas simple à
terminer il y a ce pion à 7 aussi qu'il
faudra les récupérer un jour il fait F
H3 sur cavalier prend F3 il y a dame il
y a dame F3 il fait fou prend F7 oh et
là il y a fou G2 roi G2 H1 dame échec
tour prend H5 cavalier F4 et dame prend
un mat c'est finito pour Wesley Wesley
seum oh il a le seum très très joli le
finish t prends H5 cavalier F4 roi G1
dame prend à1 et c'est finito finito
Pipo al resa qui se qualifie 1 et demi à
un demi et WIS leso qui sort d dès le
premier tour il a le SE oh il a un seum
monumental
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe terrible pour
Wesley qui s'est fait défoncer bah ça
fait déjà un français pour demain
qualifier naturel en tout cas bravo
jamais trop insinuisé quand tu se fais
défoncer ça va pas être facile quand tu
connais les techniques ouais quand c'est
tous les jours des fois c'est pas facile
mais moi maintenant je me suis vraiment
habitué he j'en ai plus rien à
faire moi je suis devenu vraiment hyper
pragmatique par rapport à la triche sur
internet je vous le dis très franchement
moi je prends je gagne l'argent que je
peux gagner et j'en ai plus rien à faire
je je vous le dis très très franchement
ça ne ça ne le le le sujet en quelque
sorte
ne m'intéresse
pas bravo à ceux qui réussissent à le
faire sans se faire attraper ils sont
très forts donc bravo à eux c'est vous
êtes vous êtes vous êtes des beaux
escrocs c'est bien vous il y a des gens
qui pour gagner autant d'argent que vous
font des braquage à main armée vous
réussissez à le faire sans prendre
absolument aucun risque et gagner des
centaines de milliers d'euros donc bravo
à eux et puis et puis moi comme j'ai pas
envie de le faire à cause de mes valeurs
morales même si peut-être que c'est bête
euh
B tant pis pour moi mais du coup je
prends l'argent que je peux prendre et
puis et puis voilà je suis vraiment très
très pragmatique par rapport à ça et je
m'en fiche alors royalement mais une
puissance vous nimaginez même
pas mais vraiment joli he le
finish j'essaie j'essaie de de bien
mettre le
truc
et donc ouais très beau finish
d'alierza là il faut qu'il soit
digne
Wesley il a il a fait un vraiment un bon
enchaînement là
Wesley
on va voir si Maxime réussi à gagner
l'armagedon et et le mat ouais donc il
il serait arrivé comme ça
hop
magnifique magnifique
aliera
bon on va attendre on va attendre
l'armagedon maintenant Maxime contre
Yann meilleur résultat en tournoi que ce
soit IRL ou quand tu jou sur
Internet hierl c'est j'ai gagné le
championnat de Moscou moins 2400 feed
qui était un tournoi assez fort après
bon ça reste moins 2400 ho mais quand
même Moscou machin ça enfin ça joue fort
c'est enfin c'est pas rien c'est c'est
comme si tu joues un hyper fort tournoi
fermer euh pour norme pas hyper fort
pour norme de Mii hein attention pas
pour norme de grand maître mais c'est
l'équivalent de gagner un truc comme ça
parce que c'est quand même assez fort et
euh enfin c'est nul pour un joueur pro
attention he c'est juste pour un amateur
c'est pas mal et sur internet j'ai fait
top 5 du plus fort title Tuesday de
l'histoire des title
Tuesday donc pas
mal
enin pas
mal c'est un peu de la Doob aussi
attention alors attendez j'ai peut-être
pas la partie qui démarre
automatiquement ça va on a rien raté on
a rien
raté
tu as des mecs sont classé de fois à
Moscou en plus ouais ouais c'est assez
sousclass ouais c'est assez sous-classé
par rapport à l'Europe de l'Ouest
ouais c'est vraiment
sous-classé genre dans le tournoi à un
moment donné j'ai joué un mec à
1880 j'ai fait nul avec les Noirs euh
mais c'était loin dans le tournoi
heureusement mais le mec a fini avec une
perf à
2480 je
crois donc ouais il y a ce genre de
joueur un mec c un biellorus je me
rappelle mais en 2004 avir 26 en France
non ça va peut-être 24 50 quelque chose
comme ça il y a pas tant d'écart 50 100
points mais j'avais bien joué j'avais
bien joué j'ai le droit de bien jouer de
temps en temps quand même je suis
tellement mal je Tom tellement souvent
mal bien le droit de temps en temps de
faire un bon
tournoi j'avais fait ma
spéciale j'avais gagné les quatre
premières et après j'avais
fait
TR nuls Avec les noirs et deux victoires
avec les
Blancs j'ai fait ma spéciale où jouis
plus avec les noirs et jou que avec les
Blancs jouis plus j'essay juste de faire
nul avec les noirs et de gagner avec les
Blancs déjà fait une expérience partie
contre MV en classico même
plusieurs mais trop fort Maxime on a pas
envie de jouer contre lui
s y a bien quelqu'un contre qui j'ai pas
envie de jouer c'est Maxime il est
beaucoup trop fort mesdames et
messieurs mais ouais non je rappelle le
gars 1880 c'était un
bélorus je sais pas il jouit hyper
bien
il jou vraiment hyper
bien c'est quoi M je crois que c'est des
c'est genre de truc de jeu vidéo non
genre DP médiéval ou un truc comme ça
est-ce que déjà battu les G long oui
ouais je jouais pas si mal en fait hein
faut vous rendre
compte en fait j'avais des problèmes de
santé entre
entre 17 ans et 17 ans et 7 8 mois j'ai
gagné quasiment 100 points ho en jouant
quatre tournois ou trois tournois non
mais je faisais juste des perfs à la fin
à tous les tournois que je jouais entre
2350 et
2480 c'est pas terrible je veux dire par
là mais bah des j'mes oui quand même
enfin je sais pas trop comment dire
c'est pas à battre un GM c'est pas très
difficile parce qu'il y a GM et GM enfin
j'ai il y a une différence entre mvl et
Fab par
exemple ça fait desénmes malheureusement
non quand j'ai quand j'ai joué mes
tournois en Russie s'il y avait eu plus
de joueurs étrangers et plus de titr
j'aurais fait des normes mais au moins
une ah sûr mais euh la difficulté en
dans les pays de l'est quand vous jouez
des tournois c'est que la plupart des
gens sont pas titrés c'est pour ça que
vous avez même un Russe là qui est fort
sur chesscom il est il est que Maître
national mais en fait il est 25 45 feed
mais c'est juste que c'est difficile
d'avoir beoup assez d'étrangers titrés
dans les tournois donc les joueurs sont
pas titré généralement donc c'est
difficile de faire des normes sans
voyager et moi comme à la fin quand j'ai
pu régler mes problèmes de santé je
jouais surtout tout en Russie ou même
exclusivement en Russie
ben ça hypothèque toute chance de faire
une
norme mais c'est plus important le hlo
que les titres il vaut mieux être 25 50
et non titré que 24 300 et metttre
international par
exemple le titre Le Ho est plus
important que le
titre tu as regardé les parties du
nouveau GM là herdogmus ouais ouais
enfin
Woodward je connais mais ouais je le
trouve pas super enfin pas super le
celui qui m'impressionne le plus c'est
dont j'ai regardé les parties c'est
herdogmus là le il il doit pas encore
être grand maître mais le Turc là il est
vraiment très très
fort mais oui c'est c'est pour ça vous
devez vraiment pas confondre grands
maître et grands maître des grands
maîtres de premier plan j'en ai jamais
battu mais mais après
euh mais après des des grands maîtres
j'aià fait compte des grands maîtres
quand j'avais peut-être 14 ans ou 15 ans
je sais pas j'ai battu un peu plus tard
mais mes premières Nules contre des
grands mats j'étais assez
jeune mais c'était pas des c'était des
grands maîtres fatigués quoi je sais pas
comment dire ou des grands matres qui
étaient 24 ans 2440 tu vois qui qui qui
étai dans une dans une deuxè phase de
leur carrière c'est pas la même
chose faut pas confondre grand mare
grand mare quoi enfin voilà j'espère que
vous avez compris ce que je voulais dire
allez c'est parti pour cette partie
958 contre 655 on va voir si Maxime
réussit à mettre en danger la nashdorf
attendez est-ce qu'il a les blancs non
il a les Noirs j'allais me dire ouais
comme ça arrive au dernier moment les
couleurs il était affiché blanc de base
mais en fait il all les noir je disais
njdor fou des TR que nous fait Yan que
fait la
police il retourne dans cette variante
on voir si Maxime réussit à à prendre
l'armagedon et qu ma cadence préféré ma
cadence de prédilection c'était la
cadence quiil sont en train de jouer là
cadence où j'étais le plus fort c'était
ça c'était 10 + 2 10 + 5 15 + 10 j'étais
pas mauvais mais le Blitz pure c'est pas
ma cadence
réelle d'ailleurs Maxime là dans sa
deuxème partie de carrière devient lui
un un meilleur joueur
de de partir rapide que Blitz c'est pas
tout à fait la même chose en fait ça se
ressemble mais pas
complètement ça se ressemble mais pas
complètement
complètement est-ce que j'ai déjà battu
yossif non j'ai déjà joué une fois
contre yosif en partie longue on avait
fait
nul solide yosif Dorfman très beau
joueur he yosif Dorfman évidemment
bon Maxime là il a il est bien sorti de
l'ouverture j'aime bien ce H5 là ça va
permettre de faire des
H4 c'est bien ce qu'il fait
actuellement en tout cas je trouve ça
assez assez
efficace il va pouvoir venir gêner ce ce
cavalier au au coup
suivant il v maximer asstit peu de temps
parce que c'est
l'armagedon c'est parce que c'est le
tableau des perdant email cavalier en D5
Yan ça va être échangé
fouprend donc là grosso modo en
l'Armageddon si vous vous rappelez si
Maxime fait nul il
se
qualifie pour le prochain tour du
tableau des
perdants Yan qui prend le pion H5 alors
ça c'est vrai que c'est dangereux mais
il accepte le défi G6 Caval
cavalier G3 et Maxime qui peut peut-être
partir pour dame D7 grand rock oh il
peut même y avoir des tours pr H3 qui
peuvent être fort parce que quand on
prend et qu'on fait F3 à minima on aura
un perpète qui gagne ça c'est un truc
qu' faut bien se se mettre en tête c'est
que échec perpétuel gagne
pour pour
Maxime mais dam D7 il doit avoir peur
d'un fou pran G6
c'est ça qui calcule mais il a peut-être
FPR
G2 bon c'est pour ça qu'il prend son
temps la
maxime c'est pour cette raison qu'il
prend son temps il fait dame C8 alors
pourquoi il a préféré dame C8 à Dame
D7
honnêtement visuellement c'est bizarre
pourquoi je vous dis que c'est bizarre
visuellement parce que la dame en D7
elle permettait le grand
RCK je comprends pas vraiment la
différence fondamentale entre enfin
disons que je comprends que dame D7 est
plus logique parce qu'il permet grand
rock je comprends pas pourquoi maxime a
décidé de jouer dame
C8 j'ai pas vraiment la
Reff de ce coup donc vous prend G6
cavalier
D4 pourquoi est-ce que la dame serait
pas mieux placée en D7 tout simplement
ah ah peut-être qu'il veut dans
certaines variantes toucher le pion C2
j'ai
compris c'est donc ça
l'idée c'est donc ça l'idée de
Maxime toucher ce pion C2 en fin de
variante donc oui c'est c'est bien joué
de la part de
Maxime je suis néophite club depuis 2
semaines est-ce que leur niveau c'est
plus simple de nul à au noir ou de Win
au blanc c'est plus facile de faire nul
avec les
noirs que de gagner avec les Blancs ça
c'est sûr Yan qui a rattrapé Maxime
autant ça c'est une bonne
nouvelle
il joue fou4 Maxime qui va devoir
échanger je pense qu'il va prendre en C
deux à la fin il va égaliser
matériellement les dam prend C de
ouais non ça va le faire là pour Maxime
il a besoin que de nul hein je je le
rappelle c'est ça qui fait la
différence s'il était obligé de gagner
ou que le match continuit en cas de
nul son avantage serait pas forcément
euh incroyable ah mais attendez on est
de nouveau pas sur le direct
direct attendez je crois je crois qu'on
est on est de nouveau pass sur le sur le
direct
direct je sais pas comment ça s'est
passé mais on s'est
fait on s'est fait
trict mais je sais pas comment on est
sorti du direct direct mais peu importe
on est de nouveau
dessus donc là k G3 il va faire roi D7 3
Maxime ça y est là il a vraiment un un
l'avantage ça devrait lui
suffire donc ro des7 le roi qui va venir
en E6 c'est les pions qui vont avancer
c'est
parfait
ah il joue bien Maxime il joue bien
Maxime
aujourd'hui
il a raté un petit peu une partie mais c
elle est très très
propre donc après ce match vous pourrez
suivre le choc entre laavic et
jospem et le perdant du matchav jospem
affrontera
mvli Maxime qui revient avec son
cavalier là il a une super
position
mais il faut pas il va pas falloir trop
contrôler parfois quand on a besoin que
de faire nul on joue de manière un peu
timorée c'est ce qu' va falloir l'écueil
qu' va falloir éviter pour
Maxime de jouer trop
timoré
il va
falloir serrer la vis côté côté
français il va falloir serrer la vis
peut-être doubler la tour les tours sur
la colongg mettre le fond H4 ça ça peut
être pas
mal souvent la meilleure manière de de
faire nul c'est de jouer le gain par que
disit toujours mon coach si tu veux
faire nul joue le gain
mais c'est un bon conseil
hein c'est un très bon conseil là l'ordi
redonne égal je comprends pas trop
pourquoi enin si je comprends pourquoi
en gros fallait doubler sur la colonne g
pour pouvoir taper G2 et là il réussit
avec les Blancs à casser le
centre
bon non il affrontera alerza ils
affrontent alza avant d'affronter ouais
ils affrontent alza et après ils
affronteront le perdant de l'autre
match bon peu importe le tournoi avance
petit à petit vous l'avez
compris
l'étape avant et après il y a
l'étape laavic machin et après il y a
encore l'autre étape de l'autre qui perd
bon c'est c'est complexe le système
double élimination peu
importe là Maxime qui est en train de
d'un peu la partie
va mettre le pion D3 cavalier C3 roi E5
fou F4 il est en train de se retrouver
mal la maxime
ouais ouais non là c'est en train de
très très mal se passer pour
Maxime le F4 a fait mal
c'était pas visuel hein comme
coup ça semblait pas pouvoir nous faire
si mal mais c'est vrai que ça nous a
maintenant ça nous a laissé le le fou
actif là devant les pions et ça nous
gêne et ça nous gêne grandement
même c'est pas fait c'est pas fait ni
pour l'un ni pour l'autre il va jouer
fou G5 je pense
ici il fait fou F6 heureusement cétait
le seul bon coup là a que tour 8 qui
tient c'est chaud mesdames et
messieurs fou
C7 alors là c'est E3 F B6 C4 non ça va
pas être trouvé ça il va faire fou des
il va faire fou Maxim je pense c'est le
coup
logique et sur fou F4 revenir en F6 il a
E3 wou alors ça c'est vraiment pas
facile fou B6 roi C4 fou prend3 cavalier
D4 incroyable W ça c'est un coup de
grande grande classe au
3 ça c'est un coup d'immense classe
mesdames et
messieurs parce que c'est c'est vraiment
dur fou B6 roi C4 fou PR3 c'était quand
même l'idée des des blancs et là il y a
cavalier
D4 cavalier D4 c'est dur hein tellement
dur comme coup mais tellement fort parce
qu'en fait sur fou prend des4 fou prend
des4 et il fait fou des4 non il a quand
même pas jusqu'au bout mais fort quand
même ça va être chaud ça va être très
chaud
non il a pas il l'a pas en fait
ouais il l'a eu mais pas pour les bonnes
raisons c'était trop dur ça paraissait
vraiment très
dur en fait il a à peu près la bonne
idée mais il y avait qu'un seul ordre de
coup qui
marchait et là il va finir par se faire
chasser par tour
4 ça va perdre les
amis ça va probablement perdre pour
Maxime allez roi des 5 seul coup Maxime
qui trouve encore cavalier E5 qui réussi
à ramener le cavalier vers C4 là il a
très bien joué mais il a plus qu'une
19 c'est dur F6 il stabilise G4 allez
B5 alors
peut-être alors
peut-être 2 minutes contre une TR je
crois qu'il commence à y avoir une
seconde de rajou à partir du 40e du 60e
pardon il lu reste encore 16 qu Maxime
là avec aussi peu de temps il aura
toujours peu de temps mais sans rajou et
là il fait tour C8 c'est bien joué il
veut ramener la tour en C4 voilà alord
don B4 qui qui gagnait carrément mais
c'était quasiment introuvable avec
l'idée tour C2 D2 mais tour C4 c'est
tellement le coup que tu as envie de
jouer sur G5 je suppose qu'il veut P on
prend et là faut tour4 W tour4 est très
très très très très fort parce que tour
prend roi prend quand il fait cavalier
F3 ça va déloger le
fou mais il va y avoir H5 H6 de l'autre
côté il l'
Maxime c'est hyper
complexe mais alors quand je vous dis
hyper complexe c'est vraiment hyper
complexe mais je crois qu'il a un
cavalier qui revient en G5 sur échec
quand les noir joue H7 donc là il va
faire cavalier F3 c'est sûr ah roi F3
terrible ça laisse
G5 Maxime qui laisse G5 la gaff ultime
ah c'est terrible de pas avoir fait
cavalier F3 qui était le coup vraiment
évident et la varance c'est H5 et D2 H6
cavalier F3 H7 cavalier cavalier
D5 mais là maintenant Maxime qui va être
trop court les noirs qui vont pousser le
pion en G6 alors il va sûrement faire
fousser un d'abord
ouais il peut faire aussi G6 cavalier
prend et G7 Maxime qui tentera cavalier
E4 G8 et
D2 donc il joue fou C1 qui est encore
mieux joué ouais
il va prendre une fois mais s'il prend
un cavalier D6 le pion va
avancer Maxime va
s'incliner il peut pas récupérer les
pions un peu de se pour
Maxime qui
s'incline
malheureusement dans une partie de
plutôt mauvaise
facture euh ouais c'est ici la la la
l'erreur décisive est arrivée là il
fallait commencer par cavalier F3 qui
était le coup évident en plus je sais
pas pourquoi il a pas jouer fou C1 et D2
tout bêtement il aurait eu la même
position avec quatre temps de plus H4
euh cavalier F3 et H6 cavalier
G5 et je suppose que Maxim aurait tenu
cette
finale quoi que c'était peut-être pas
sûrin enfin là je joue plus les coups
humains
mais ouais ça ça ça ça devait
tenir ça devait
tenir gros choke ouais bon c'est pas
grave he je vous
assure c'est un peu dommage pardon j'ai
mis j'ai mis le mauvais screen mais
c'est
pas c'est pas
gravissime
je suis en train
de préparer les
caméras et après on va faire une petite
pause
ah va falloir que je réussisse à trouver
euh
les parties donc bien sûr on va suivre
le match
lazavic
Alcantara
c'est fin pour Jer ou là non c'est pas
du tout fini là on va avoir le match en
quatre parties maintenant c'est là que
le le plus intéressant va va commencer
là on va voir les matchs extraordinaires
entre laavic et rosé Martinez Alcantara
qui est vraiment le gros match et et on
a un peu le Side Event carlen fait CF
mais ça ne fait que
commencer là on va on va avoir
encore
encore au minimum quatre parties à
voir on devrait être là jusqu'à 21h
21h30 B on se retrouve on se retrouve
après une petite pause le temps que les
joueurs se se mettent en place à tout de
suite les amis saviez-vous que vous
pouvez pimenter vos parties en ligne et
vous analyser avec des emmojis il vous
suffit de cliquer sur l'icône emoji puis
de sélectionner votre emoji et de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur les chiquers vous pouvez
choisir parmi une multitude de notations
de coup d'animation d'émoticone et même
vos personnalités préférées du monde des
échecs les émoticones et les mojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
coup et les animations spéciales restent
sur les chiquier jusqu'à ce qu'elles soi
effacé pour se faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji ou de cliquer sur le
bouton tout effacé
essayez-les tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bon alors les amis ça devrait
commencer ça devrait bientôt
commencer donc attendez je suis en train
de bien mettre les trucs en place
euh pour qu'on puisse se lancer
correctement donc là il va falloir
changer
ça et mettre ça comme
ça c'est 00 le
score et
c'est rosé Martinez je
pense et là c'est Denis
lazavic
et le score c'est
00 et on va se mettre dans l'autre sens
c'est la zavi qui a les
noir je pense que c'est
ça
et ouais Maxime éliminé ouais Maxime
éliminé Magnus est maintenant grand
favori de la compétition il était déjà
depuis hier parce qu'en
fait je pense pas que la zavic Martinez
ou fedosf puisse le
battre
en fait je suis même certain de
l'inverse on va voir j'espère qu'on va
avoir un beau match entre la zavic et
Martinez je pense qu'on va avoir quatre
nuls et un Armagedon et et attendez et
oui et c'est pas quart de finale des
perdants is c'est ça on a on a je me
disais bien que j'avais oublié de faire
un
truc voilà on est demi-finale des
gagnants on attend hein pour le moment
c'est pas c'est pas encore
reparti
Maxim ch ouais Maxim
choc allez ça part45 cavalier F3 C6 fou
B5 cavalier
F6 donc une
antiberlinoise
c'est un
choix solide de la part de la
zavic c'est un choix très
solide on va voir s'il réussit à faire
parler la poudre dans cette
partie il f qu' revient en
C2
fou6 donc ça se
développe ça essaie de se rappeler côté
côté rosé
Martinez les qure parti ah oui aussi le
4 parti en ha à droite
merci
beaucoup bon ça réfléchit pour le
moment les noirs qui donnent
l'impression d'avoir une position
correcte
on va voir s'il réussisse à à faire le
travail ou
pas mais à mon avis la zavi qui va jouer
hyper solide c'est toujours sa stratégie
dans ces matchs
là il joue très très
solide il est extrêmement solide comme
joueur laav très difficile à
battre
et firou il a
gagné
il a
gagné donc dame 7 c'est
solide c'est même très
solide je pense que les Noirs s'en sont
vraiment bien sortis he là dans
l'ouverture la position est vraiment
vraiment très solide d'ailleurs on voit
la barre d'évaluation qui donne qui
donne égalité mais je vous dis ça mais
visuellement pour moi il y a pas de
doute hein que ce soit
égal c'est juste très visuel hein enfin
les la position des pions est symétrique
au centre et les deux joueurs ont un
développement
équivalent donc à vrai
dire les Blancs ne ne peuvent pas avoir
l'avantage ici c'est pas possible en
vérité moi je pense si je pensais qu'un
des de joueurs avait l'avantage ce
serait plutôt les Noirs mais il y a pas
de raison non plus c'est juste
visuellement je jou avec les Noirs mais
c'est vraiment que du goût je serais
conscient que la position est égale ce
serait qu'une question de
goût il y a de la CE partir de quand
dans ce tournoi là je crois que les
joueurs ont déjà gagné ceux qui sont là
peut-être déjà 10000
dollars il me
semble puisqu'il seraiit reversé euh en
loser bracket s'il perdent mais ils
auraient déjà passé
euh deux trois joueurs de loser BR donc
je pense déjà gagneré 10000 balles
chacun je nai je n'ai pas
le le price pool en tête entre
guillemets mais pour moi ils sont déjà
au-dessus des 10000
un peu le seum pourel bon n'est pas le
seum moi je écris après franchement
là il a lui-même pas le seum donc il
n'est pas le seum pour
lui il n'a lui-même pas le
seum pourquoi tu Jos frérot il est même
pas francophone en fait il y a plus
de il y a plus de joueurs français ou
francophones là dans le tournoi enfin il
y en a un mais dans dans le tableau des
des perdants donc il pourrait revenir
dans le
tournoi mais qui n'y sont pas
là donc t
D8 place au cent c'est solide hein je
pense que les blancs sont peut-être très
légèrement mieux
mais ça changant
D5 je pense qu'il va reprendre du pion
mais après euh il doit
hésiter
ouais B la position reste égale he pour
le moment dame
D6 firou ou qui firougeura nepo
miashi
ah je sais plus comment ça marche ce
tableau des perdants à chaque fois je me
perds c'est sûr qu'il joue N pomchier
qui joue pas le perdant de Fed CF
Carlsen ah je je m'en sors
pas
un qui est content placer le mat de
Greco en partie mais écoute c'est
bien ça rentre petit à petit les
échecs bravo à
toi d'avoir placé ce magnifique
mat j'aime beaucoup ce mat de Greco
c'est un de ceux que je préfère
placer on dit de Magnus en final il va y
avoir le drama du non mais il va ils
vont pas battre Magnus en final hein il
perd donc contre Magnus 100 %. il est
trop fort
Magnus Magnus est trop fort
mon tour russis il va se placer sur la
colonne
D après le tableau chesscom firou j r
contre le perdant de ce match
ah il joue en croisé
alors le le tableau des perdants c'est
un truc de tête j'arrive jamais à le
faire c'est pas intuitif enfin si un
côté intuitif mais pas
trop bon donc ça va être un match très
très dur pour alirea au prochain
tour ça va être un match très très
difficile
le tweet de NPO il a encore
tweet son tweet est marrant ouais
mais
oui il y a plus d'erreurs côté mvel
ouais marrant son tweet
bon
ah ouais c'est 4 bien
joué vous êtes pour qui vous vous êtes
plutôt
euh vous êtes plutôt team jospem ou team
lazavic
quel est votre chouchou pour ce
match quel est votre
chouchou mais les blancs commencent à
être mieux on le voit la barre mais on
le comprend c'est parce qu'ils ont la
paire de fou et la dame en F5 est bien
placée
en tout cas ça réfléchit côté côté
jospem
team
Armagedon on du Jos spem
Carlsen je suis assez d'accord avec ça
ouais je pense qu'on ve jouer au spam
Carlsen mais Carlsen va le
massacrer
ok bon c'est solide quand même côté
laadav le ass
B4 prise
d'espace
je su car ça être une boucherie je pense
aussi on peut se
tromper
ouais Carl trop
fort pour le moment une position à
l'avantage des blancs quand même le
chouchou peut
gagner le chouchou peut
gagner le chouchou peut nous mettre le
premier punto de la journée
ça nous mettrait Gucci ça une victoire
du
chouchou victoire du chouchou mais très
Gucci il est quand même mieux le
chouchou peut-être fou C5 pour le
chouchou alors après si les dites-vous
que les joueurs ont une deuxième cam he
derrière il y a une deuxième cam de
sécurité derrière pour voir leur
écran
tu peux mettre Magnus si vous voulez
voir Magnus vous pouvez aller sur la
chaîne principale sur la chaîne
principale il parle quasiment pas je
vais je vais un peu les mettre de mon
côté mais il parle quasiment pas du
chouchou et de la zavic en
fait ils essayent vraiment d'éluder les
parties du chouchou et de et de la
zavic ils en parent le moins
possible ça c'est vraiment
terrible ça fait mal au cœur en vrai
ils sont à fond sur la partie Magnus
Magnus qui est plutôt bien dans dans sa
partie contre contre focf mais normal
Magnus contre ces joueurs là c'est
quasiment du
100% il joue souvent nettement moins
bien contre
Magnus Magnus il a une classe supérieure
qui les fait
déjouer il y a un micro
aussi non pas vraiment
il est censé être allumé mais c'est
assez facile de déjouer un
micro micro c'est vraiment facile à
déjouer extrêmement facile le micro à
tromper
la zavi qui tient
ouais bon Magnus qui est en train
d'écraser fedo CF mais ça c'est sûr hein
Fed CF contre Magnus il a vraiment
aucune
chance
Magnus c'est vraiment complètement
gagnant mais vraiment le Main EV c'est
vraiment j SP
laavic coupprsord ça l'air pas mal B5 ve
jouer pour tour prend B5 et
attaquer je crois que Magnus a gagné là
je crois que ça win pour Magnus ou ça va
être un massacre je pense Magnus va
gagner le tourno avec une facilité
déconcertante et voilà une gaffe et là
la gaffe contre Jos spem ça va être puni
la gaff va être punie par
jospem alors comment on punit ça je mets
pas l'ordi pour pas me spoil voilà ça y
j spem a trouvé là il fait une petite
mimique ça y est il
regarde comment on gagne
ça que c'est tour prend D5 dame prend F5
t prend D8
ouais ça a été trouvé et T prend des4
facile j spè c'était sûr j spè tu fais
une gaffe il te punit allez la zavic et
oui le chouchou le
chouchou et ça y est ça danse oh ça met
bien
puni puni par le chou
chouchou et là il va remettre la tour en
E4 le chouchou il est
facile il est trop
facile bon c'est bien beau début de
match frosé Martinez
on va peut-être avoir notre finale
demain entre rose et Martinez et Magnus
Carlsen il confirme son statut je vous
avais annoncé he quand je joue contre
lui je vous dis je considère qu'il est
minimum top 5
mondial il va confirmer là en allant
dans dans une finale du champion chest
tour et il faut pas minimiser la
performance he il y a très très peu de
joueurs qui réussissent à faire
ça si on combine ça avec toutes ses
perfs en en title en Arena King et
cetera il est il est réellement top 5
voire même peut-être top
3 il est très très bon allez il va
falloir conclure
là il faut
dérouler
ah là je crois qu'il peut faire pion
prend et il a du Fou F1 Ohou le piège la
zavic et oui Jos spem qui se fait
piéger ça
ais ça c'est beau ah il est
dégoûté
ah le chouchou qui a raté aussi gaffe
contre gaff dans cette
partie allez il y a peut-être encore des
gaffes qui nous
attendent
aïe aïe aïe a AE AE AE quel
dommage allez le
chouchou je pense pas qu'il va réussir à
la gagner
celle-là G5 c'est pas mal tenté mais je
crois qu'il y a pion
prend pion prend dame prend fou G4 non
ça va pas suffire il a voulu faire
passer FO H5 mais ça passe pas il
commence par tour 6 quand même il est
malin le truc c'est que on prend H4 FO
H5
F8 ça va pas suffire mais c'est bizarre
là ce qu'il
fait je regarde sans ordi pour pas me
spoil quand Mme F H5 encore il peut pas
faire F H5 là ah il le fait quand même
ah mais a G6 seul
coup très bien défendu
là il y a peut-être
perpè peut-être tour 2 dame C1 et encore
ro G2
mais il peut reprendre le pion ah il a
l'air d'être
dégoûté comment il a raté
ça il aura un cavalier là il pourrait
vraiment faire
mal mais avec seulement une tour c'est
dur B il faut juste faire
nul
dommage dommage
dommage bon les amis on va faire une
toute petite pause et on va
revenir il a l'air d'être
dégoûté il a l'air d'être
dégoûté je crois que ça reprend très
très vite à tout de
suite
quel est le meilleur moyen de suivre
n'importe quel événement échiken Surpat
du monde au tournois des candidats en
passant par le speedess ou les title
toesday
chess.com/events courouv tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables base retrouver
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contre-rendus
quotidiens les bios des joueurs les
règles des partages et plus encore vous
pouvez même participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats pour
tenter de gagner des abonnements premium
alors rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nulle part
ailleurs
il les amis ça reprend
déjà ça reprend
déjà attendez non on était
ouais c'est la Zav avec les Blancs c'est
ça cette fois-ci contre rosé
Martinez
Alcantara il y a déjà eu nul dans la
première
dame 3 dame 7 il va jouer cavalier
C3
bon la zavic généralement il joue solide
il joue que pour
nul c'est pas trop son point fort de
presser les
avantages ça comre Maxime NPO Maxime NPO
c'est fini he maxime a
perdu pe pas jouer 5 là avec les
noirs
je crois que le vainqueur de ce match il
se qualifie au prochain champion ch tour
en plus je crois que si tu es finaliste
du tableau des vainqueurs tu te
qualifies je suis pas
sûr jou avec C5 is c'est l'autre
possibilité
je sais pas s'il va prendre ou jouer au
5 peut faire les deux en
vrai mais peut-être prendre
plutôt
peut-être faire5 ouais non je sais pas
les deux son possibles voir ce que dit
la turbinette la
petite mais plutôt pour P on prank que
pour 5 mais c'est ses deux premiers
coups
ouais je pense j'aurais plutôt fait
ouais je sais
pas il a hésité un
moment
non je suis pas par nul bah la première
elle était complètement gagnante he
Mathieu
pour pour rosé
Martinez il a raté une pièce nette de
plus s'est pris un il s'est pris un
piège
quecoup vouz ouais ouais bah rosé
Martinez il était à Plus+ 7 + 8 il était
complètement gagnant il a donné une
pièce en un enin en
deux
il joue
3 le cavalier en D2 puis en
C4 la zavi à l'avantage ça c'est
sûr qu'il va
pouvoir
le transformer ça c'est une autre
histoire mais c'est t plus pe de fou
pour jospem il a pas
converti contre une dame c pas très dur
à converdir mais il s'est pris un
piège
première gaff tactique du tournoi pour
les deux ouais il y a une gaff tactique
de la zavi et a une gaff tactique de de
jospem ils ont tous les deux fait leur
gaffe
tactique
h ouis sur C D2 il a peur de cavalier E5
hein je
suppose
je pense que rosé Martinez est quand
même
favori déjà il a globalement des
meilleurs résultats sur internet que la
zavic quand
même je pense qu'il est juste plus fort
en fait
légèrement TB c'est bizarre comme
coup
peut-être pas si bizarre que
ça
un but parce qu'on enri mais en vrai
quoi que laa et jospem feront des gens
premier degré vont croire qu'il y a h
sous roche ouais mais tu as raison
leopodo c'est pour ça que ikarou il dit
que ces tournois là ils peuvent plus
exister
la question
c'est comme je l'ai dit très très
souvent le fond du problème c'est pas de
savoir s'il triche ou pas c'est de
savoir que s'il le font n aucune manière
de le d'en être
sûr donc à cause de ça en fait
ben le fait de pas pouvoir savoir si les
gens trichent ou pas c'est ça le
problème c'est pas on peut pas savoir
c'est le doute en fait le
problème
mais oui je suis d'accord avec toi on
nen sait rien à vrai
dire et personne ne
sait mais du coup
euh si tu peux pas t'en t'en t'en
assurer ni d'un côté ni de l'autre si tu
peux être ni sûr que oui ni que
non ça tue un peu
le l'intérêt sportif ou espportif de la
compétition c'est ça en fait le problème
c'est de pas pouvoir
savoir il y a combien la gagne sur le
tournoi là ils ont déjà gagné 10000 je
crois et s'il gagnent le tournoi ils
gagneront
je pense qu'il calcule C4 d' prend C4 F
prend3 ah il y aura pas il y aura pas
tour
C8 mais peut-être pe faire C4 C4 prend4
F G4 pion prend tour
C8 tour prend C3 je sais pas ce que ça
vaut mais je S 5 c'était un bon coup
mais B4 un bon coup
aussi donc A6 tour
D4
il faut qu'il prouve en réel pour calmer
les rumeurs moi je crois que ça change
rien c'est même pas le fond du problème
c'est même pas une question de prouver
en réel ou quoi le fond du problème
c'est que même si euh MV voulait tricher
tu pourrais pas t'en rendre compte donc
partant de
là tu pourrais pas le voir en fait c'est
c'est ça le le fond du
problème tu tu pourrais pas le savoir en
fait tu peux pas le
savoir c'est fou je suis aussi é de en
ligne de de AG of Empire 2 avec des
gains de plusieurs milliers d' il y a
pas de triche du tout ambiance bon
enfant mais c'est peut-être plus
difficile de tricher qu'aux échecs aussi
Jof rempire monsieur poir et c'est
peut-être plus visible et il y a
peut-être moins d'argent là il a quand
même 1,7 million de d'euros de prix par
an hein rien que sur ces
tournois
mais l'autre problème aussi qu'on a dans
les échecs actuellement c'est que la
situation elle pourrit depuis plusieurs
années là maintenant ça fait au minimum
depuis 2020
ouais ça fait depuis 2020 donc ça va
faire 4 ans
maintenant que j'entends très très très
très très régulièrement des suspicions
sur beaucoup de joueurs et il y a
toujours pas de
contrôle suffisant en tout cas pour
enlever ses doutes 4 ans c'est beaucoup
hein à coup de 1,7 million par an ça
fait déjà du du price P à hauteur de en
plus c'est même pas assez tu vois il y a
a il y a trop d'argent en jeu par
rapport au
par rapport à la puissance des
suspicionss en fait et du coup la
situation elle est de plus en plus
pourrie
la situation aux échecs elle est elle
pourrit depuis un long moment
maintenant et euh et ça ne fait
qu'empirer
lu évolue je sais pas si Kevin a essayé
avec ses potes ou juste pour voir mais
c'est curant moi j'ai pas essayer hein
parce que c'est trop tentant après il
vaut mieux pas
installer Dame des
tris donc ça c'est censé être une
gaffe alors que le coup est assez
logique
visuellement mais c'est comme s'il avait
compris que c'était une gaffe au moment
où il le
jouait il réfléchit à un
truc ça pas été trouvé par la
zavic
donc ça échange et on s'attend à une
deuxième
nulle
bon
il prend à
4 compliqué comme
position
vraiment
compliqué tour G1 d'accord il se
place su en réaction non mais il a rien
de spécial tellement suspect là
franchement c'est une partie comme une
partie quoi
enfin puiss regarder he il y a eu des
gaffes CIT quoi le mon coup sur D 3 je
sais pas je peux regarder pour te dire
moi j'ai absolument pas trouvé mais
quand il a vu dame D3 ça se voit que il
était pas
content et alors le bon coup c'était
cavalier4
dame prend le3 et cavalier F6 échec roi
H8 t prend le3 ouais il a dû le voir
après avoir
joué mais ça se voit que tout quand il a
joué dame D3 il a pas été
content
mais il a joué le coup il a eu l'air de
se rendre compte
genre quasiment instantanément après que
c'était que c'était mauvais il a
peut-être vu cavalier E4 dame prend3
cavalier F6
hein
le 4 cétait trouvable
ouais a fait
F5 fa F3 ça peut-être être une des
première partie que la zavi gagne on va
voir va faire F H5 tour G3 F
F7 tu peux voir en jouant ça tu peux le
voir ouais comme toute façon c'est c'est
je suis 100 % d'accord avec ce qu'a dit
ikarou quoi et pourtant c'est pas
quelqu'un avec qui je suis tout le temps
d'accord la f H5 c'est le coup le plus
humain qui existe c'est une faute mais
c'est ce que j'aurais fait pour touer à
F F7 mais je suis d'accord avec ce qu'a
ditarou dans sa
vidéo il a tout dit en fait c'est juste
que ce genre de tournoi avec autant
d'argent ça peut pas ça peut plus
exister en
fait à l'heure
actuelle il y aura toujours la
mê la même
impression non fou non là là par par
exemple la partie est hyper logique hein
enfin je veux dire il y a aucun coup
bizarre en fait
va faire tour G3 qui prend D6 il va
gagner t G3 il y a encore cavalier
E4 donc il fait qu' D4 ouais il va faire
cavalier C6 ce
7 t G5 c'est plus fort ouais et tour
point
F5 c'est très bien joué mais c'est hyper
logique
la faire t prend F5 cavalier C6 et
E7 h bien joué qui prend F5 plus précis
bien
trouvé
il va prendre 7 prendre F4 et là il va
décaler le cavalier en C8 je pense ah
cavalier G6 c'est joli et E7
ouais victoire de la zavic
mais mérité hein complètement
mérité mais on voit que la partie là
elle était complètement normale mais la
première aussi hein c'était deux parties
vraiment normales il y a rien à dire
quoi la partie était complètement
logique he il y a il y a vraiment rien à
dire
et Carlsen là qui est perdant contre
fedosef il a les noir là
Magnus c'est pas Sophie Rouja
évidemment
il devrait la perdre
Magnus alors est-ce qu'il va la tenir
finalement estce que fedosf a raté un
truc pas trop
dur pourquoi il a pas fait cavalier C2
ah parce que ça ça
tient il va pvoir faire roi
B4 à 6 sur roi prend B3 il cavalier à 5
échec je crois mais roi B5 il va
attraper le pion et faire nul bien
joué ça l'amuse d'avoir tenu la finale
ok il la tient Magnus ça
l'amuse 1 et demi un demi l'éteint
immédiatement sa
caméra bon ben les amis on va refaire
une petite petite pause et ça devrait
bientôt reprendre je crois qu'il y a une
toute petite pause entre les les parties
2 et 3 et on se retrouve très vite pour
la troisème partie il y a deux joueurs
qui mnent au score à tout de suite les
[Musique]
amis
les amis on va bientôt ça va bientôt
reprendre donc on revient on revient sur
les parties et sur ce match qui oppose
la zavic à à rosé Martinez alors on voit
le nom de rosé Martinez qui a
disparu on va voir si les qu' en
capacité d'égaliser mais la zavic la
zavic est costaud
hein je crois qu'il a en jeu aussi une
qualification pour le prochain tournoi
hein je crois que les deux joueurs si
c'est comme l'année dernière de la
finale des gagnants
joueront sont automatiquement qualifiés
au prochain tour he donc il y a quelque
chose il y a peut-être bien du du 20
30000 dollars he de d'enjeu au final
dans dans ce
match c'est quand même pas rien c'est
beaucoup
d'argent surtout que c'est c'est de
joueurs vivent dans des pays euh non pas
que ce soit peu d'argent en France mais
euh et et sans
vouloir paraître au teint par rapport à
ces pillà au Mexique ou ou en bélorussie
c'est c'est de coquet de
somme on aimerait bien que les deux les
gagnent mais bon malheureusement il
faudra un vainqueur et un
vaincu
ça va
reprendre
ça ça devrait reprendre très vite hein
ne vous inquiétez
pas
ça reprend dans 30 secondes
normalement
qui a l'air un petit peu stressé mais
c'est qu'il y a beaucoup d'argent en jeu
quand même pu là a le match en
main ça joue vite
bon ça joue vite ça joue vite on va voir
ce que ça
donne qu'
revient7 on va voir si rosé Martinez
réussi à mettre son adversaire en danger
ou
pas
cavaliat à
5 ça a pas l'air
d'impressionner rosé Martinez ce
plan ça n'a pas l'air de du tout l'
impressionné je pense que que la zavi
tient bien le match
là c'est un joueur solide je vois pas
perdre en fait perd très très
peu
un cavalier
H5 est stressé mais il a pas l'air
spécialement content quand il gagne
c'est vrai qu'il s'en
fout mais je pense que c'est juste qu'il
est pas
expressif
il va jouer pour
F5 g de savoir ce qu'il fait j'imine
qu'il va jouer B4 avec les Blancs on va
voir
en tout cas c'est vraiment un bon joueur
hein ce
laavic
H3 il veut se faire une case pour le fou
mais bon il se laisse prendre en G3 il
le prend pas il fait
F5 il va jouer
F4 cavalier un peu bizarre en H5
peut-être parce qu'il veut pas revenir
en F4 mais il a il a permis de pousser
quand même CIT le cavalier en A5 qui
vous paraî c'est bizarre tout à l'heure
vu que j'ai un
décalage
h il a pas l'air bien en fait rosé
Martinez Alcantara il va se prendre G5
dame 8 dame
G6
ah les noirs sont vraiment
bien le F H2 est tellement
bizarre FA 6 c'est pas
mal tour G1 ah là il est en train de se
faire
massacrer ces pièces sont trop mal
placées espè de plan à l'Est indienne
ouais bizarrement mais avec le pion en
D3 pas en
D5 ça pourrait tourner vite court hein
ce match
aujourd'hui
je pense qu'il va continuer par cavalier
G7 et
G5
la dame
7 Mo principale il va faire fou au
prochain
[Musique]
h ah les noirs sont quand même très bien
hein les noirs sont quand même très très
bien bon on va voir
euh on va voir s'il s'en sort mais ça
pourrait être la dernière partie de ce
match on aura un beau match hein demain
peut-être entre lazavic et
Carlsen je c c'est que le tour G1 il
mène pas à grand-chose en
réalité
ok F 6 F
C2
ouais je SPME qu' a l'air un peu
désabusé
hein passe vraiment à côté de sa
game
il a pas bien joué cette
partie lui qui habite maintenant au
Mexique
lui qui habite maintenant au
Mexique rosé Martinez qui qui vient en
D2 il l'air d'être écuré de sa
partie
ouais c'est vraiment
difficile chavalier F6 c'est logique
bizarre que l'ordinateur permettre un
point
d'interrogation va peut-être prendre F6
et revenir en E4 avec l'autre cavalier
mais
bon son pas si grave hein il a quand
même un beau Dieu de pion E5
F4
il joue F3 il
consolide pourra peut-être faire passer
le fou via G1 à un moment donné qui
sait prend le4 avec le
fou décision som toute
bizarre il peut reprendre des trois de
du cavalier des ou des de pions c'est
dans les tris semble logique en
fait pr du cheval
fait le truc le plus
neutre il fait le truc le plus
neutre sur cavalier prend il va jouer
dame prend ou pion
prend il remet la tour en
H1
il a fait une tête bizarre après avoir
le tourchin mais pourquoi il a joué
tourchin
tempo ça fait vraiment penser à un
miscilick il a raté quelque
chose il a raté qu' prend C3 et D4 et E4
ah
ouais tellement bizarre ce Tourche un
tempo
il a tout de suite vu que c'était une
gaffe il l' tout de suite vu que c'était
une gaffe mais c'était tellement bizarre
comme coup j'ai rien compris à la partie
honnêtement il est passé complètement à
côté de son
matchchin c'était vraiment
zarbi
ouais perdu lazavi qualifié en finale
match qui aura
pas qui aura pas tenu ses
promesses là la partie était tellement
naze mais alors là tourchin j'ai
vraiment pas
compris je comprends même pas le coup en
fait
je c même pas l'intérêt du coup en
fait mais oui non c'était pas des belles
parties
franchement bizarre de voir l'UR tempo
coup bah il a fait plusieurs fois dans
le match chat Deschamps de se rendre
compte tempo après ses coup qui faisait
une
gaffe
c'est pas la première fois qu'il le
fait mettre le fond pour éviter cavalie
au3
ouais bon enfin vu la position qu'il
avait c'est quand même un lourd un coup
lourd de conséquence pour le jouer
tempo
c'était un coup lourd de conséquence
c'est une grosse gaff mais ça se voyait
qu'il était pas dans sa
partie pour moi ça se voyait qu'il était
pas du tout dans sa
partie
j'essaie
de en fait j'essaie de biencadrer
Carlsen je sais pas pourquoi je l'ai pas
là
voilà je l'ai désolé
hein et donc il a les Noirs Magnus
ouis je je veux mettre les score en
place c'est 21 donc une nul
suffit ça veut dire quoi jouer tempo ça
veut dire jouer
vite mais euh ouais décevant décevant le
le match là qu'on vient de voir il y a
pas eu de pas eu de belle partie jusqu'à
maintenant on n pas vu de belle parties
en fait peut-être la mieux c'est celle
de sa la plus marrante celle de saut
contre
firouja Magnus qui a l'air de connaître
cette
ragzine pas vraiment une ragosine mais
genre de ça ressemble dans l'esprit
c'est pas une ragosine en vrai
c'est une Nimzo mais ça ressemble c'est
G5
H5 Magus déprimé ouais il était bon il
est full déprimé
hein il joue avec sa tête full
déprimé je pense qu'il va gagner le T
tellement
facilement
hier Magnus V qui a gagné c'est Magnus
qui l'emportait mais sa qui a reperdu
aujourd'hui contre
alirea
dame je pense qu'il va jouer cavalier E2
fou B5 il clou le cavalier ça empêche
cavalier prend des4 effectivement qui
était la
menace il va peut-être jouer fou
des7
prition est vraiment compliqué
là VI va jouer fou F5
ouais pour se mettre en vis-à-vis de la
dame ah il a l'air vraiment très très
bien la
Magnus
demainav je pense qu'il va gagner sans
sourcer
aussi TR grosse div de niveau
c'est du pain béni pour lui ce tableau
vraiment du pain
béni vraiment beaucoup trop fort par
rapport à ce
field les seuls qui pourrait gêner c'est
nepo ala mais là il est plus en
préparation des candidats
il vient de finir V et tout il a pas
l'air en en giga en giga forme et sur
cavalier G3 là il veut dame à 4 car il
prend un f prend C6 c'est bien
joué ah il réfléchit parce que c'est
bien joué la part de F
CF c'est même très bien
joué
ah il a été bon
là-dessus et sur cavalier prend
C3 faut prend C si échecs
intermédiairees
les dames prend
F5
[Musique]
h prends
H4 ve dire à fait CF qu'il a pas trop de
coup utille par que sur Grand qui prend
C3 F prend C6 puis on prend prend F5 et
qui prend de échec à la
fin non son mat plus dur à Magnus
c'était hier contre so en fait là si B
fa de CF après normalement la zavic
c'est cadeau enfin je vois pas comment
c'est pas un
penalty
et après il aura de vies en
finale contre un joueur qui se sera
cassé les dents sur tout le
tableau dame B3 alors dit donne faute
mais la position semble tellement
dure le coup qui réfute c'est le plus
logique c'est grand rock
ouais ça va être trop facile pour
Magnus trop
facile il est tellement
fort il est tellement plus
fort
mais après tour8 qui prend F2 ouais ça
va rentrer ça va rentrer très
facilement très très
facilement je pense qu'il va faire grand
rock et que ça va rentrer tout seul
ouais céit sûr qu'il avait beaucoup trop
facile je crois que F CF il est écœuré
là
je crois qu'il est
écœuré F prend C3 il va jouer BC
j'imagine
mais là là là il y a plein d'options
pour les Noirs mais j'adore la première
ligne de l'ordi parce que c'est un coup
auquel j'avais pensé juste tour H6 pour
protéger latéralement je pense que c'est
ce qui va faire la tour
hyperlope ça fait tellement
mal
tour H6 ça paraît vraiment
fort après c'est pas le seul coup en
mêmeord donne H3 comme tout aussi fort
tour h G8 mais tour H6 j'adore tu viens
défendre toute ta toute ta 6e rangée tu
pourép du A6 après tu pourras revenir
avec le cheval vers
A5 tellement facile Magnus tellement
fort il est tellement fort il fait tour
r 6 c'est sûr c'est le coup humain en
fait maintenant qu'on a beaucoup étudié
avec les ordi on a ce genre de coup
beaucoup plus facilement
qu'avant mais ouais c'est tellement fort
ça défend tellement
tout
très bien
joué très très bien joué mais pas
difficile pour pour un joueur de son
calibre comme
coup il est pas content d'un
truc
il est mécontent d'un truc je sais pas
lequel F4 tour
G6 mais s'il peut un jour prendre en G2
après c'est l'autoroute
hein il va faire à 6 au
prochain
ah tellement fort
Magnus
F3 il essaie de
chasser là encore il y a plein
d'options je pense qu'il va faire
cavalier G5 cavalier
E6 leordi don t reprend G2 comme gagnant
si on prend et prend le4 mais
bon ça semble vraiment pas obligatoire
surtout que le fou défend le cavalier E2
[Musique]
donc ça sble vraiment pas obligatoire
mais cavalier G5 cavalier E6 c'est
facile le pire c'est que sur F prend C6
même s'il doit faire pion il remettre le
rang en D7 il est tellement mieux mais a
pas l'air super content de lui alors
que il m' associ H3 bah il joue que la
première ligne mais il est mécontent de
lui il y a un truc qui le gêne
probablement mais je sais pas
quoi c'est peut-être pas la partie
hein
peut-être 3
F2 peut-être a cap tué une varante qui
finalement marche
pas mais bon F2 au pire il fera H3 il va
encore tout affaiblir
ouais à tempo en
plus là il peut prendre G2 et sur k
prend F5 faudra qu'il réussisse à faire
promotion
cavalier
je pense hein qu'il faut qu'il réussisse
moi si
j'étais si j'étais fait def j' ser
cavalier pr on sait jamais qu'il est
l'autopromotion et qu'il trouve pas
comment
faire je crois que c'est alt mais ah il
l'a
eu VO là il y a tout qui
gagne cétait bien tenté de la part de F
CF je pense qu'il a voulu
tenter une autopromotion
ratée je pense juste faire dame D7 tour
G8 enfin c'est juste complètement
gagnant là pour pour les
Noirs c'est une
formalité c'est
fort c'est fort
il joue tellement bien mais ce que je
disais là il y a pas de de joueur de son
calibre il faut pour pour qu'il y ait
des joueurs qui puissent gêner Magnus
faut qu'il ait ikaro faut qu'il y ait
Maxime faut qu'il ait Wesley enfin là
Wesley il l'a battu il faut qu'il y a
alza faut qu'il ait Yan ça c'est des
joueurs qui peuvent poser des problèmes
à
même si Magnus gagnera la plupart du
temps mais quand on est dans des joueurs
même plus du second rideau mais du 3è
rideau même du herigizi du ah erigizi a
quasiment aucune chance contre Magnus
mais ça peut quand même poser des
problèmes du keer on l'avait vu à la
Coupe du
Monde du pragananda tous ces joueurs là
peuvent gêner magdus
mais je dis bien gêner hein pas battre
gêner gêner
gêner
et le terme
adéquat t G5 fort en fait fallait éviter
les cavaliers G7 qui avit prend G7 t pr
G7 il av fou F5 mais t G5 ferme bien la
porte
mais oui les joueurs du 3ème rideau sont
sont trop en dessous pour pour un joueur
du calire de Magnus il est tellement
fort c'est beau parce qu'on sent que fa
CFC qui va
perdre
lui-même
mais il accepte son
destin pas tenu la pression nous dit oui
coupe du mondeer avait craqué mais sous
la pression il avait pas
été dominé par
Magnus fait prend des qu pour rendre le
matériel et avoir une position qu'il ne
perdra jamais
c'est du Blitz là c'est ça là c'est du
rapide il est combien fait de CF je
pense qu'il est 26 80 2690 Fed
maintenant Maxime al jou ce soir ils ont
joué avant y LG 56 on a vu une défaite
de
Maxime et une victoire
d'aliireza F point F5 c'est trop triste
ça enlève trop d'attaque donc il veut
pas le
jouer
4 cavalier E7 pas mal joué ce F4 ça
garde les pièces en jeu on voit que ça
fait un peu su Magnus
F4 dame C2 c'est très bien joué là ce
qu'il vient de faire alors peut-être
peut peut-être voler quelque chose fedos
qui
sait qu' va vouloir F H4 et F prend le 7
il a vraiment trouvé des bons
coups Magnus qui devait penser que fou
prend F5 d pr F5 était forcé mais là
tout d'un coup il se retrouve en léger
danger on va voir
écoutez pourquoi pas s'offrir un
Armagedon moi je prends moi plus ça dure
plus je suis content donc à vrai dire la
personnellement je suis vraiment
supporter de fedo CF à 200 % allez roi
B8 c'était le le seul coup qui
gagnait sur fou D4 il veut tour H5 tour
prend H5 et dame
G4 j'imagine quelque chose comme ça dam
H3 ah tour H5 et dam H3 est vraiment
fort fedos qui y croit
là il y croit complètement la
fedos moi ça m'arrangerait vraiment ça
ferait durer encore un peu le spectacle
au moins un petit un petit une petite
demi-heure encore mais F6 tient tout
tour H7 tour point F4 EF et dame
G4 alors
peut-être euh le truc qui est bien c'est
que la tour H7 tape de concert avec la
dame ah ça pourrait me mettre Gucci là
une petite victoire de fedos
complètement inattendue Magnus qui était
tellement gagnant
il est en full
troll et ben dis donc j'étais mauvaise
langue je vous ai dit c'est des joueur
trop faible pour Magnus mais c'est vrai
qu'il était tellement en contrôle ça
paraissait tellement
facile alors il veut quoi sur ah t
prend7 maintenant il y a dame prend H4
parce que la dame a perdu la
connexion je crois que c'est l'idée je
ne suis pas
sûr
ouais Magnus qui était vraiment trop
facile mais on l'a vu il avait des
attitudes un peu
étranges oh dame G2 c'est joli mais il
se trouve que la finale gagne pas
d'après
l'ordi qu'est-ce qu'il est fort ce
magnusos qui a raison à mon avis d'aller
jouer dame dam
H2
il va faire fou C deux là je pense pour
couper la
défense pour C8 et là il faudrait qu'il
réussisse à gagner un
pion peutêtre va jouer tour D7 ah il y
aurait dame3 du coup al peut-être tourus
il fait dame G3 d G3 c'est bien joué
peut-être dame C3 se reconsolider sur C6
on aura dame B4
peut-être Fos qui fait
durer il s'accroche en tout
cas Magnus
aussi alors à un moment donné il faudra
réfléchir au final mais celle-là elle
semble pas assez gagnante
encore va sûrement remettre la dame en
C3 Magnus qui est solide hein quand même
il fait roi C3 il se laisse échanger en
C5
il va gagner le pion
F6 il faut le prendre he non il monte le
oh c'est malin ça il veut pas perdre de
temps il veut monter le
roi al là tour C8 semble
forcé mais ça y est il a une forteresse
Magnus et fedos c'est pas sûr qu' puisse
rentrer il va jouer pour fou C2 à mon
avis à mon avis il va mettre le fou en
C2 ah c'est bien joué
ça ah c'est très bien joué Magnus qui va
s'en
sortir
là il a très très bien joué
Magnus ah ouais il a été il a été
clnique gagné le pion C5 change vraiment
beaucoup de
choses ah il a vraiment été
bon avec tellement peu de
temps
al Fed il veut essayer de passer à mon
avis le fou en G4 et aller vers vers
C8 il va essayer de gagner enfin de
d'échanger les
pions il va mettre le fond H3 je pense
ou en F5
ouais ouais il fait il fait ce qu'il
peut de mieux c'est troquer le pion et
mettre le roi dans le coin mais je crois
qu'il peut pas avancer
maintenant fa qu'il puisse amener le roi
en C5 mais il peut
pas il peut juste pas en
fait donc il va essayer ramen le fond E8
mais la tour elle doit être pas mal
placée sur la colonne
C en tout cas il se bat ah c'est bien
joué ça il menace t B5
ouis il défend vraiment bien
bien il va même pas pouvoir gagner le
pion en fait mais c'est dommage pour
fedosfi il a eu un petit
shot mais là ça y est les noirs sont
organisés il est noir sont organisé il
pourra plus chasser le roi du du
schmilblck il est bien battu de la part
de focf vraiment bien
battu le r D2 parce qu'en fait il a
encore l'idée de faire tour B1 tour C1
il va le faire he tour B1 tour C1 il va
réussir à gagner le pion là ah tour B1
il y a tour B4 mais fou prend C6 ah et
roi C5 il pouvait pas gagner le
pion Magnus qui reeréfléchit au au truc
raté par
fedos mais peut-être pas raté du tout en
fait
on peut pas on peut pas on peut pas
faire évoluer le
schmilblck il y a pas de manière il y a
vraiment pas de
manière
dommage dommage pour fedo CF mais il va
falloir
accepter il a tenté fou G4 et passer le
roi
mais
ah il un coup de pion donc ça redonne 50
coups de plus D4 c'était
dommage il a remis 50 coups de plus
là
et il a filé un pion
elle va durer cette
partie parti sous le signe de la
caillass hein pour
moi
on pas vraiment couper le roi
encore comment est-ce qu'il veut faire
ah il cutte le roi
maintenant bizarre de pas avoir fait fou
il a une autre idée en
tête que je ne comprends absolument pas
pour le
coupok va pour enenvoyer le roi sur la
6e
rangée mais tout à l'heure il pouvait
faire quelque
chose de plus intéressant là il faut
qu'il fasse tour G5 échec mais non mais
fallait faire tour
G5
ah il veut cut la tour oh il est tombé
oh là là là là là là là là oh la
catastrophe oh il est tombé et ça va
aller en Armagedon
ah c'est
magnifique ça va nous faire des belles
heur sup ça ah extraordinaire B ça me
met très très bien il y avait juste
tourage 3 c'était complètement
nul Magnus qui a troll il s'est
endormi
ah c'est étonnant là ce qu'il a fait il
était tellement complètement gagnant
dans la partie c'était tellement facile
et puis je sais pas il s'est endormi
il s'est juste
endormi
magnifique c'est magnifique bon les amis
on fait une petite pause comme ça on est
de de retour après avec avec l'armagenon
ça va être sympa à tout de suite les
amis saviez-vous que vous pouvez
pimenter vos parties en ligne et vous
analyses avec des mojis il vous suffit
de cliquer sur l'icône emoji puis de
sélectionner votre emoji et de cliquer
avec le bouton gauche de la souris sur
les chiquers vous pouvez choisir parmi
une multitude de notations de coup
d'animation d'émoticonees et même vos
personnalités préférées du monde des
échelles les moticon et les emojis
disparaîtront au bout de quelques
secondes en revanche les notations de
goût et les animation spécial reste sur
l' chquers jusqu'à ce qu'ell soit
défacée pour se faire il suffit de
cliquer avec le bouton gauche de la
souris sur l'emoji de cliquer sur le
bouton tout effacé
essayezles tous et amusez-vous bien sur
Chess.com
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors les amis ça va
reprendre le score c'est donc de par ça
va être
l'armagedon on va bientôt avoir la
partie qui va s'ouvrir Magnus qui qui a
fait un peu n'importe
quoi donc normalement ça va être Magnus
qui all les noir mais c'est pas sûr
c'est pas
sûr je suis pas sûr que les en les
enjeux a déjà été été faits en tout cas
ce qui est sûr c'est que magmus ça a pas
l'air content mais c'est vrai qu' il
avait tellement la partie gagnée c'était
c'est assz incroyable ce qu'il a fait il
était il était à moin 5 ou moins 6 sur
l'ORD av besoin que de nul puis après la
finale elle était vraiment complètement
nul il a il a enchaîné un nombre
d'erreurs
incalcula pour
perdre mais ouais il y a quelqu'un chez
lui apparemment à qui il demande de
dégager allez je crois que c'est en
train de
démarrer alors attendez il faut voilà ça
part et c'est bien fait CF qui a les
pièces blanches donc on va se mettre du
côté de
Carlsen qui a 630 il a décidé de prendre
les Noirs attention il y a pas de
rajou à mon avis il a envie il a pas
envie d'aller se faire le loser bracket
et gagner 40 milliards de match
Magnus surtout qu'il a pas envie de
repasser après par la phase de Calif
s'il va pas en finale après il doit
refaire les califes et cetera donc c'est
une partie quand même assez importante
pour
lui il réfléchit après faut
F4 F F5 fa CF qui a l'air vraiment bien
concentré cavalier C6 Magnus là qui
prend évidemment les choses au sérieux
he il a il y a quand même pas mal
d'argent en jeu dans cette
partie est-ce qu'il va jouer rock ou
cavalier à 5 ça semble être les deux
coups logique fait cavalier
5 un joli coup cavalier à 5 et
maintenant il va me probablement mettre
le pion en
C6 c'est chose fait cavalier5 dame B6
peut-être non il a Leser
roquet allez c'est pas mal ce qui fait
pour le
moment G4 il va mettre le F
H7
bien
joué et H4 il va falloir jouer cavalier
E4 maintenant c'est le ROG
bonito mais non il est malin il est
malin fa CF après la positiontion est de
nouveau bien pour Magnus allez un petit
coup de F6 si on prend foupran et
chasser ce ce cavalier moi je suis quand
même plutôt type Magnus c'est un joueur
que j'aime beaucoup quand même hein
il il a un jeu quand même assez
exceptionnel fou
B4 tour C1 et peut-être maintenant il
veut F6 je pense qu' F6 il en a besoin
pour casser la structure et et venir
taper fort il le
fait je crois qu'il est en train
vraiment de dominer l'ouverture Magnus
qu'est-ce qu'il est fort quand même ce
Magnus mais ouais F6 c'est bien joué
après puis on prend dame prend cavalier
D7 c'est la
ligne qui gne et c'est pour ça qu'il
fait tour prend
il a décidé il a pris le parti de jouer
vite
fedos l'avantage autant qui n'a pas qui
n'a pas changé je je mes lunettes je me
disais je voyais pas très
bien mtenant que j'ai pris l'habitude
d'avoir les lunettes de vue c'est vrai
que je me disais c'est position est un
peu les couleurs sont pas sont pas
vive il joue dame G4 il met il met une
petite pression
B leur dit mes points d'interrogation
mais c'est pas mal jouer dame G4 dame
E7 ça
défend ça peut menacer cavalier prend C3
puis on prend C3 faut prend C3 puis on
prend dame B4 maintenant il y aurait roi
D2 mais ça pouvait menacer
ça
donc le cavalier est bien protégé par le
fou aussi he c'est important de le voir
peut-être un coup comme cavalier C4 est
envisageable
potentiellement il fait fou
F5 intéressant ce fou F5 ça vient
désorganiser la dame et sur dame G2
peut-être qu'il veut ramener une tour en
F8 plus que 432 il y a pas de rajou là
jusqu'au so
60e elle va jouer tour à F8 je pense
hein ramener ramener la dernière pièce
en jeu c'est logique cavalier C4 c'est
un peu dans la même logique ce cavalier
un peu hors
jeu il faut qu'il accélère la Magnus
il est endormi aujourd'hui il a il vient
de perdre la partie au temps ce qui
était quand même très
étonnant là il a pas l'air de de jouer à
la vitesse de l'éclair allez prendre en
D3 ramener le fou en D6 il veut se
libérer la case C4 pour le cavalier
revenir proprement je pense qu'il va
reprendre de la dame fa de
CF de maintenir ce cavalier en E5 là
c'est quand même une belle pièce pour
lui puis ess-êre de faire fou G3 et
F4 son roi a pas trop de case il a un
problème il a pas assez de case
blanche il faut qu'il réussisse à jouer
vite de toute façon la fait de
CF mais Carl n pas l'air dans son
assiette il a il a pas l'air dans son
assiette il a pas l'air dans son
assiette mais le fou en
D6
il
revient sur fou G3 il veut cavalier C4
bêtement en fait il veut cavalier C4
quoi qu'il en soit il prend C4 F prend
F4 prend C4 prend C4 puis on prend C4
aussi
possible
il a pas l'air d'être en grande forme
Magnus après ça se voit sur c'est comme
quand on est fatigué les erreurs de de
déconcentration et là il a pas pris en
G5 alors l'ordi donné puis on prend G5
puis on prend G5 et fou prend E5 comme
meilleur
wou là l'ordi donne complètement foutu
après fou prend F6 dame prend C1 roi E2
dame prend H1 et dame G6 et ben
c'est du petit Magnus très franchement
heureusement que c'est
raté mais ouais bah de pas défendre la
finale dans la partie d'avant c'était
quand même déjà vraiment incroyable
il a vraiment troll mais un
level qui a déjà eu pas mal de ball
contre contre alirea il devait vraiment
perdre là ça semble être bis rpétita
pour
lui
c'est pas perdu
encore loin de là mais c'est vrai que ça
dû lui enlever de la confiance de rater
la partie juste avant là moin 6 quand
même je rappelle c une position vraiment
complètement gagnante qu'il avait Magnus
même pas difficile en
plus mais il faisait des des des mous
bizarre ouais voilà c'est ça on le voit
là la caméra il est pas il est pas
content de son jeu même quand il joue
les meilleurs cou il avait pas l'air
content ce qui veut dire que il jouait
les meilleurs coups sans avoir les
meilleurs les variantes
importantes il a encore des chances là
de faire nul attention il y a quand même
un pion pour la qualité il va pouvoir
revenir avec la dame en
défense ramener le cavalier en
C4 ça doit encore se
jouer
c'est ce qu'il faut qu'il fasse en tout
cas dame 7 là voyez la jauge montre de
nouveau
égal il veut ramener le cavalier en C4
peut-être jouer pour B6 après et
consolider la
position il a peut-être il a peut-être
eu la chance dans sa
malchance la position semble belle
celle-là pour fedf c'est pour ça qu'il
est rentré vite dedans et qu' s'est pas
mis à plus réfléchir à Dame G6 qui
clôturait he vraiment la partie tout de
suite allez faut faire cavalier C4 là
pour Magnus
vite il a plus trop le temps il est un
peu dans l'urgence sur E4 il y aura soit
cavalier E5 soit tour E6 à mon avis
cavalier E5 qui menacera le rebond à
F3
on va voir mais cavalier E5 cavalier
F3 peut-être cavalier
D6 pour cavalier F5 ouais ça y est
Magnus il est en train de placer les
pièces là et il menace aussi cavalie4
allez il a repris le contrôle de la
partie maintenant le problème c'est la
pendule de 22 seulement il est obligé de
cliquer obligé de cliquer obligé de
cliquer faut venir avec du cavalier E4
là c'est quand même le coup évident faut
pas qu'il perde trop de temps là il
s'endort Magnus oh là là là là là là
ouais ouais bon ça c'est vraiment signe
de fatigue hein ça a dû festoyer
hier vendredi soir ça a dû
sortir ça a dû sortir festoyer
ça c'est un des un des premiers signes
de fatigue ça les de tanker du temps de
perdre un peu
la la sensation
temporelle on a l'impression de
réfléchir plus qu'on qu'on le doit le
temps est un peu distordu alle est
peut-être passer par derrière Magnus si
tu es sorti hier
soir c'est peut-être dans le thème
il essaie de passer par derrière comme
ça contour la
défense allez il
contourne il
contourne tour G4 il peut peut-être
jouer tour F6 même juste mais
l'important c'est de jouer vite là
maintenant plus qu'une 33 il a encore 25
cous à jouer avant de récupérer la
seconde parcou 25 coup c'est beaucoup
allez revenir avec le cavalier en D6
retaper F5 E4 voilà c'est bien là là
c'est bien ce qu'il fait Magnus sur4 il
a pion prend tout bêtement il en train
de faire le taf là Magnus c'est bien là
il menace cavalier4 fourchette il menace
cavalier F5 sur tour G4 il y a cavalier
peut-être cavalier oh il y a C5 pour ou
il y a C5 il y a C5 qui gagne ça
déconnecte avec la tour oh alordi mon C5
c'est terminé c'est abandon C5 Magnus
non il rate encore oh là là là là là il
a dans le mauvais sens ah c'est terrible
ça il l' dans le mauvais sens mais ça
marchotte quand même parce que sur dame
D2 il a peut-être tour pr F3 j'imagine
que c'est ça son idée roi prend dame F5
tour F4 damage 3 mat c'est ça son
idée
ah là là là
là donc tend le 4 plus ou moins forcé
allez Magnus cette finale là tu vas
quand même pas nous la perdre toi le
meilleur joueur de finale de tous les
temps qui n' des égale
elle doit quand même pas être très dur
pour un tel que lui allez tour B6 le
Magnus tel que Magnus devrait la gagner
bquatro
maintenant
ah ça y
est c'est prend B4 t prend B4 je
crois clôture fort tour C2 tour prend à
4 et et ça gagne là il va enfoncer le
pion en B3
ah il va encore roi E4 ro E6 roi
D3 ça doit gagner Magnus une nouvelle
fois qui tank pour pas grand-chose ah il
fait pion prend parce que tour prend B6
C2 et comme il a pas joué RO2 ça passe
il va mettre la tour en B3 le roi E6 et
tour à3 ouais là ça va gagner tranin ça
va gagner ça devrait gagner mais ça va
surtout ne pas
perdre ça tente un micro contrejeu pour
fedo CF mais ça sera pas assez Maxim qui
va faire C2 échec roi prend C de Tours
prend E5 tu reprend G5 t reprends E5 ça
fait un échec ça ramène le RO en C4 et
ça c'est ciao
a échec échec échec échec échec échec
échec échec échec échec échec échec
ouais monsieur Fed CF là il faut
s'arrêter
ouais bon
respecte-nous ah il y a pas de rajout
temps en
fait il n'y a pas de rajout de temps
ah c'est ça en fait rench il met pas le
rajout de temps dans
l'Armageddon mais voilà les coups sont
répétés la nulle est obtenue par Magnus
et fedo CF éliminé mesdames et messieurs
de ce tableau des vainqueurs Magnus qui
aura joué une demi-heure de plus
aujourd'hui mais qui s'en
sort mais qui s'en sort donc victoire de
Magnus Carlsen dans ce match qui va
rejoindre demain lazavic mais attention
à Magnus a pas semblé être en en superbe
forme j'ai envie de vous dire à demain
mesdames et messieurs on se retrouvera
sur les coups de 17h pour la suite de la
compétition avec tout d'abord un match
entre Alireza firouja et Martin
Alcantara et ensuite on aura laavic
contre Carlsen bonne soirée à tous ciao
ciao quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échiken
Surpat du monde au tournoi des candidats
en passant par le speed chess ou les
title Tuesday
chess.com/events courou tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et l'État